you
all right welcome everybody we find
ourselves once again on the precipice of
another disinformation session with
mango Mussolini the tangerine terror as
many of us now know him I appreciate you
joining me we are in the Room at the
White House press briefing room and we
will this is scheduled for 15 minutes
from now based on how sparsely populated
the room is at this point in time I can
only imagine that it's going to be a
little more than 15 minutes before this
one gets started but alas we will see I
would expect a lot of disinformation
today why do I say that I say it because
I'm sorry I see people are just reacting
to my hair I just went for a run and
it's really windy out and I haven't had
a haircut for months because of what's
going on
so anyway I hope it's not too much of a
distraction but I really can't do too
much about it right now so we're gonna
have to just deal with it why do I
expect a particularly high amount of
disinformation today basically because
we are starting to see a little bit of a
slowing of the curve we are apparently
approaching the peak but it will only be
the peak if we continue social
distancing measures and so I would
expect that Donald Trump as always will
simply go too far the way he's gone too
far with chloroquine the way he's gone
too far with everything right so that is
why I would expect that and we're gonna
get into some of those numbers
momentarily welcomed on Twitter twitch
YouTube and Facebook thank you for
joining me once again these streams
really have been in the context of I
should lower my chair actually so that
my full hair fits in I mean it's crazy
for my hair to be out of the frame there
we go it is but now I'm really low but
at least my hair is fitting we these
streams have really been what has been
saving us in terms of being able to sort
of maintain relatively level revenues
because YouTube's down 35% we had 389
people canceled memberships last month
it's been crazy so alas here we are
thanks to John II for grabbing a beta
membership on YouTube Ben says would you
host live stream of Cuomo press
conference
day two highlight the differences
between those and Trump's absolutely the
reason I haven't is the scheduling is
usually when we have interview scheduled
for my broadcast show or we are in the
middle of filming or that so typically
there at 11:00 a.m. Eastern time and
it's just not the best time for us which
is why I've not been able to do it so
far
Karolina Altamirano says quarantine hair
don't care yeah I mean I just this is
what it is you know I can't I can't do
much about it you should see when I run
or when I'm running out in Boston the
entire thing is ISTEP sort of shakes and
this happens where it comes down and
usually I'm running around and it's it's
almost like by the time I'm back it's
typically like this and now that you
can't touch your face when you're out in
public normally I would go like this
every time right it starts falling and I
go like that I can't do that anymore
when I'm running because it is you know
you can't touch your face when you're
outdoors so you can't you just can't do
it so I just run around and it gets
really really bad okay let me get into
some of the data now what do we see
going on recently and why is it I
believe Donald Trump today is going to
start talking about like we're almost at
the end of this thing here's why we are
now up to 1.3 3 million known cases
globally and just about 75,000 deaths
when we look at the countries with the
most cases of course we are number one
America first 362 thousand cases Spain
Italy Germany all in the six figures
with a number of contenders quickly
arriving a nearby now with the US
numbers yesterday let's actually go down
to the charts yesterday the u.s. saw a
pretty significant reduction in new
cases and we saw a pretty significant
well not a pretty significant we saw a
reduction in new deaths now already
today we are probably going to surpass
that yesterday we had 25,000 new cases
we already have more than that today
yesterday we had 11 65 new deaths
with four hours to go in the GMT day we
are already almost there so yesterday
was merely a blip and my fear is that
Donald Trump is going to pretend like
we're almost there it's starting to go
away when we still have a lot of work to
do a lot of work to do
meanwhile actual good news the IH Emmy
model has been updated with new data
from over the weekend I think they
missed a day or two over the weekend of
updating it daily currently the peak is
still expected on April 16th but
potentially with 3130 deaths now a lot
of people are confused by this how could
that be the case when the margin now or
the confidence interval goes goes all
the way from on that day 1,100 to 7500
well what's going on is there there
seems to be more uncertainty this window
now potentially 7500 deaths on the peak
day we're only 10 days from that we just
don't really know what the remaining
curve is going to be is it going to be a
leveling out very soon with around 12 to
14 hundred deaths per day is it going to
spike to the top of this confidence
interval where we might have 8,000 dot
people die in one day we just don't know
right now and that's a lot of why we
just need to keep doing what we're doing
and seeing how low we can get this curve
one bit of good news again to the extent
that we can believe it as of yesterday
we were expecting 93 thousand deaths in
this first wave of the virus in the US
that has been revised to only 82,000
that's a reduction of almost 15%
overnight with the latest data all we
can do is stay at home and and do
everything we can do individually
because every day the model is changing
and we just don't know where this is
ultimately going to shake out let me say
a few thank-yous to some people I want
to say thank you to Garrett soom who is
new member number one today at join
pakman.com also want to say thanks to
martyr
Deskin thanks Margaret you are new
member number two and Bryan Horrigan is
new member number three today also Miko
alton in' is new member number four
today at join pakman.com a few super
chats continuing to come in john
sebastian paneros says oh sorry let me
get back to our live video of the room
as we await the press conference people
in the room now wearing masks that is
new we had not seen that to date but now
people in the room wearing masks okay
John Sebastian Pinera says David
auditioning for Doc in Back to the
Future absolutely Gareth Thomas says
keep up the good work David you are a
voice of sanity pare tearin' says you
remind me of a race encountered in Star
Trek discovery can't remember the name
please people help me
Eureka Gauss says hi why is my
membership called SOI boy what is the
reason behind it we have taken back the
power the right wingers like to insult
left wingers calling them soy boys it's
a really dumb insult we're just making
fun of them by actually calling one of
our memberships level levels soy boy
unknown prodigy says Trump will be in
super arrogant mode the stock market is
up sixteen hundred the virus may be
reaching its peak which we all which all
will validate his idiocy
I expect exactly that today my friend
let me say thank you over on twitch to
plague of the earth for gifting a
subscription Gilmore goth for
subscribing for seven months in a row
real Derek Burton has subscribed and
says is the whole hair thing just the
distraction it is it's distracting me
that's for sure
turkey bacon and cheese has just gifted
twenty subscriptions on Twitch really
appreciate that as we are in the middle
of a of a hype train over on Twitch okay
Oh a second mask appears in the press
briefing room we may now see a lot of
masks in the press briefing room
probably not Trump but we will soon see
some masks there
okay let's look at a few other things
here um Rudy Giuliani Rudy Giuliani is
back and Rudy Giuliani seems to have
half of a haircut okay I want you guys
to look very closely at this video and I
guess I can't really zoom it because
then it doesn't look right Rudy Giuliani
appears to have shaved the right side of
his head the left side of his head he
did not it's very very odd but what I
care more is not how Rudy Giuliani looks
but what Rudy Giuliani says and Rudy
Giuliani is now promoting
hydroxychloroquine while half of his
head is shaved all right let's take a
look I think we should let doctors
decide whether we should use
hydrochloric win not the National
bureaucracy you know this disease can
kill you and if hydrochloric win has
side effects none of which are death by
the way that's not true then those side
effects I think may want to endure
because of the risk of death and it may
be different if I'm 25 or if I'm 75
those choices should be given to doctors
right not to the bureaucrats in
Washington who want to go through three
blind tests when we finish the three
blind tests you know most of America
could be gone and they sit there in an
ivory tower whereas the guy sitting at
Mount Sinai Hospital was the person
walking in who's 65 year old 65 years
old 104 temperature and I sent one there
just the other day first thing they did
before they even talked to him he's
sending people to hospitals he's talking
like he's a doctor now has given
hydroxychloroquine and it's banned in
New York so these are lies it's not
banned in New York stockpiling it is
banned in New York and Michigan the
rumor was New York and Michigan banned
the drug no they banned the stockpiling
of it so that it's actually available
for clinical trials saying you know just
about everything Rudy says is not true
there and he's really a danger and
somehow he only cut the hair on half of
his head which is really weird full
coverage of that tomorrow okay here is a
non-scientist bomb-thrower Peter Navarro
this guy's an economist listen how he
says
he is qualified to recommend chloroquine
to people take a look let you go to four
ports beginner it's wonderful you're
saying a second opinion here what are
your qualifications to weigh in on
medicines more than dr. Anthony found
you why should we listen to you and not
doctor pouching well let me suggest John
that later in the day you have William
grace on another famous doctor in the
city of you'll remember that wasn't the
question
work he has he can talk eloquently about
this but John there's doctors disagree
about things all the time my
qualifications in terms of looking at
the science is that I'm a social science
is a PhD and I understand how to read
statistical studies whether it's in
medicine the law of course the problem
is we don't have proper randomized
controlled trials with chloroquine yet
there are no actual real studies to read
what's wrong I'm sorry that doesn't
qualify you to treat me you know it
doesn't hang on John John John John so
anyway there's Peter Navarro's
qualifications for recommending
chloroquine these guys are really
something else really and it's dangerous
it's very frankly dangerous let's see
here Dean Draper says David now looks
like a rebel - Charlie says Trump's hips
swivel it actually seems like his hips
are locked as well and he's swiveling
from the ankles
that's very funny I like that that's a
that's a that's a good one so we will be
doing a bingo today I will paste the
link in the twitch chat and in the
YouTube chat and moderators you can keep
the link for when people start asking I
encourage you to play along I am going
to generate my bingo card now and there
it is so we will we will be playing
bingo I encourage you to play along it
makes these marginally more tolerable
marginally more tolerable so I encourage
you to play along with me once we get
started numerous masks now in the room I
believe that this is a coordinated
effort and a good one to do the safe
thing but also to make Trump look like
even more of a tool for insisting that
he just doesn't want to wear
for Vanity's sake wiping down seats we
see a lot of things being taken very
very seriously now in the room which i
think is very very important and I like
seeing that Charlie says try okay we did
that one already
these are super chats coming in and I
encourage anybody watching on YouTube to
send a super chat Zack Bushman says hot
take mathematical literacy illiteracy
especially statistics and probability is
one of the greatest and most insidious
threats to modern democracies I agree
and critical thinking Jakob grave says
loving the hair David loving the
coverage even more thank you for what
you do
Ryan Henry Dean says Boris is getting a
lot of positive wishes for recovery how
do you think people would react if Trump
went into the ICU I don't know the
answer to that I don't know the answer
to that let me say thank you to a couple
of other really great people
Trina parem is new member number five
today at join pakman.com and James
Rowley is new member number six at join
pakman.com I will I'm only going to
mention this once today I'm really
paring down how often I mentioned
membership this program mostly is funded
by people who get a membership on my
website okay now a lot of people are
tightening the belt because things are
tough with the virus in March very sadly
we lost 389 members we've never had 389
members canceled it's only April 6th and
several dozen more have canceled and
these are people who were writing to me
and they're saying David it's not that I
don't like the show but we're having to
tighten the belt right and I completely
understand that so if you are in the
camp of someone that can afford a couple
bucks a month consider grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com set it and
forget it is the way I say it the coupon
code up there 2020 now will save you 66%
that makes a monthly membership two
bucks a month if you pay for the year
which I recommend it's only $1 80 a
month if you can't afford it I'm still
here we're doing the streams these are
for everybody but
you are in a position to grab a
membership we really do appreciate it
because YouTube revenues down 35% again
we lost 389 members last month so this
is sort of what we're doing instead and
encouraging folks to sign up don't feel
obligated to use that discount code a
lot of people are paying full price a
lot of people are not either way we
appreciate it very very strongly and
join pakman.com is the is the place to
sign up now I also as always would
encourage you if you're watching on
Twitch make sure you're following my
twitch channel if you're watching on
YouTube make sure to hit the like button
and subscribe all of this stuff helps
growing the audience helps we've started
the streams also on Twitter and on
Facebook we're doing multi-platform
we're doing everything we can
essentially and everybody's working from
home on our staff we found out today
actually that someone caught the the
virus at our office building of course
we haven't been there for two weeks
which again it costs money to
decentralise and it was completely worth
it because it's keeping everybody safe
we haven't had to do any layoffs we
haven't had to do ours reductions or any
of that stuff so in any case the message
is thank you to everybody who's been
who's been supporting our work ok a
couple of other things I wanted to go
over we played this one already this is
a funny thing and it's a little bit
cringy many of you know that Joe Biden's
wife is dr. Jill Biden but she's not a
medical doctor she's a teacher and
Whoopi Goldberg here comically suggests
that Jill Biden should be the Surgeon
General which it's pretty cringy I'm not
gonna lie let's take a look at it and
dr. Jill becomes a Surgeon General Joe
Biden's wife I see that you know he
would never do it but she it's yes she's
a hell of a doctor she's an amazing
doctor so anyway she's a hell of a
doctor really what what is it what is
her specialty exactly turns out her
specialty is education so that's not
great that's not great we don't you know
it obviously Donald Trump would appoint
a non doctor to be Surgeon General he
appoints unqualified people to positions
all the time but that wasn't the best so
not not her best moment and then lastly
here is lunatic right-wing judge Jeanine
bringing on who a religious nut to tell
us the virus is because people have
sinned it I don't know who's loony er
take a look at this given the number of
Americans and thousands have already
died oh do you you must get questions
like why would God allow this kind of
thing to happen good question well I
don't think it's God planned for this to
happen it's because of the sin that's in
the world Judge man has turned his back
on the people who call her judge without
being satirical they forgot here we have
sinned against him and we need to ask
for God's forgiveness and that's what
Easter is all about is about God so
loving the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but should have
everlasting life Jesus Christ came to
save sinners he didn't come to condemn
the world but to save the world and if
we put our faith and trust in him now
he'll forgive our sins and it'll heal
our hearts and he'll change the course
of our lives and this this pandemic this
is a result of a fallen world a world
that has turned his back on God and so I
would encourage people to pray and just
let's ask God let's ask God for help
yep well Franklin Graham I don't think
there's any question but this is giving
people a tremendous opportunity to be
somewhat introspective yes exactly so
that's what we call mental illness and
it's it's very very bad very serious and
again you know if you were yelling
there's people who go onto the subway
platform and yell that same stuff out
they just they don't have cameras in
front of them and they're not wearing
suits and we say you should be
institutionalized but you know
apparently it's okay to do when you are
Franklin Graham and and you know etc etc
okay let's see here I want to do a few
other super chats
aleksander ID says when this global
nightmare is finally over please don't
say that people will
stop with things like shaking hands and
hugging and being social in bigger
groups that would be depressive yeah I
believe I don't think that that's right
you know Trump talks about chunk Trump's
a germophobe he says maybe we'll never
get back to holding hands or you know
whatever holding hands shaking hands but
I think that we will it's just a matter
of when Donna Williams says appreciate
your work appreciate your support Donna
thank you
Madison neumes says just joined has
anyone made a troll doll reference about
David's hair yet either way thanks for
the continued coverage no nobody's
mentioned that yet nobody's mentioned
that yet
martin van Gorp says great job David
super chat from Belgium loved Belgium
hope you guys are staying safe there
also martin van Gorp says here is money
for a haircut no the suit I've not
missed a haircut because of a financial
act now that I'm looking at it full
screen I look like a lunatic I just have
not been you know you can't go and get a
haircut anywhere right now so I'm I'm
being safe that's all that's all that's
going on if you're just joining us on
YouTube please make sure to smash that
like button and completely destroy that
subscribe button it really helps us
somehow we've had 12,000 people show up
to our stream and only 600 have hit like
which is twit the people on Twitch can't
believe that low ratio twitches
absolutely furious with YouTube right
now because of that if you are just
joining us we will be playing trump
briefing bingo
yesterday we missed China hopefully
we'll get that today we didn't get you
should be ashamed yesterday I'm hoping
we get that and Trump was not sweating
yesterday so maybe we will get sweats
visibly I have pasted the link to the
bingo card a bunch of times in the
twitch and YouTube chat and moderators
please also when people ask about it go
ahead and paste it for people the
invisible scourge
I am hoping for and the bingo the bingo
link has been pasted in the chat
many times many many many times so keep
an eye out for it there very important
stuff okay let's see here
our website is actually getting hammered
right now by people trying to get
memberships I believe it is holding up
although it is getting a little
borderline but so far we're releasing as
much power as we can and let's see if I
can thank a few people here where did I
leave off okay Christopher Panetta is
new member number seven at join
pakman.com Colin Webb is new member
number 8 gage Robbins is new member
number 9
Tom Bicknell is new member number 10
Carol Sundin is new member number 11
Christian gaffe-filled is new member
number 12 I'm feeling good about the
name pronunciations today Mary Rafferty
is new member number 13 today Frank
Witter is new member number 14 Korie
lancelot ax is new member number 15
Christian boy is new member number 16
martin van Gorp is new member number 17
Thank You Erica Townsley number 18 today
steven jackson is new member number 19
today Peter Hedlund is new member number
20 thanks Peter
Michelle Compu bear why splat deign
that's a mouthful is new member number
21 today Zev Dean's is new member number
22 philip dickinson is new member number
23 Boris sur avec is number 24 Frank
gjermund is new member number 25 so as I
like to say let's go for 50 whoa things
just got very crazy there let's go for
15 everything going wrong here okay
let's look at a few other super chats
from folks coming in ryan nawicki whoops
sorry Ryan nawicki where did that go
ryan says David please put your hair
down every inch of social distancing as
a
important keep up the streams by the way
are you still getting dmca slammed on
streams note recently we have not been
getting copyright strikes on streams
fortunately I don't know what changed
Stephanie Wagoner says I think your hair
represents the insanity of Trump he is
making us all crazy with his narcissism
and lies love all that you are doing
thanks Stephanie I appreciate your
support Paul Newman has sent a super
chat Fred Power says Johnson in
intensive care
Dominic Raab takes over yeah that's a
big story that is that is a huge story
and we'll probably discuss it in more
detail tomorrow when it comes to you
know someone's medical condition I don't
want to speculate or I want to make sure
I'm only reporting things that we know
for sure
waffles jirafa says most annoying
sibling or cousin in Ozark three
siblings are cousins
maybe I haven't gotten to that part yet
I mean I know you know there's there's
uh Wendy Byrd's
brother is a character but I don't know
what other people there are really to
think about great show though fantastic
program season three of Ozark Bryan
Holaday says the right weaponizing
religion is not talked about often
enough also Christianity at its core
seems to not agree with right-wing
politics in many ways it doesn't but it
doesn't matter it's still in the United
States is intertwined Erika Townsley
says did you catch John Oliver's episode
about one American news I missed it I
did not see that
thanks to rillette for the super chat
david rowe says do you believe the
numbers from China I don't know
I'm unsure I'm very very unsure about
the China numbers for reasons I've I've
talked about before and will talk about
again Danny Thompson says
hydroxychloroquine side-effect is hair
loss with your hair right now you might
want to look into it Minnesota has the
lowest cases per million in the United
States yeah I you know I'm just not sure
if I am starting to get my hairline
receding a little bit in the corners
there but then when I look at old
pictures it's I think it's been like
that forever
I don't know George Bush says your hair
looks perfect today sweetie says love
the hair as well as the show you know
it's insane the number of super chats
related to my hair
it really is let me say thanks overrun
twitch the beautiful beautiful people on
Twitch want to say thank you to pappy
mcpeepers for subscribing the Kal of ik
has subscribed [ __ ] smash has
subscribed says if you need some TP and
are on the North Shore I'll leave some
outside for you Oh cliff on pole coal
Steen has subscribed with prime zafon
has subscribed with prime yo vivo has
subscribed with prime and so has Taz
6:02 thanks very much
very much appreciate the support from
folks over on Twitch and we've got a lot
of exciting things coming up soon on
twitch if you're joining us on YouTube
remember you can get your message up on
the screen and the lower left there via
super chat Paul colleton and Ashton
graves have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions Paul Newman says I hope
this crisis will lead us on the right
way it is an aha moment for me what we
see now what's wrong with our world
let's make the world a better place a
beautiful message pair tieran says do
you think Wormtongue Steven Miller is
behind some of the loony speech yeah I
assume Steven Miller is involved in some
of the some of the writing and putting
together of Donald Trump's coronavirus
speeches for sure
betty swal --ax has grabbed a youtube
membership Gaylord Winchester says thank
you for making these quote press
conferences tolerable Daniel Krieger
says I'll give you $20 to make your hair
emo tomorrow I don't know what that
means I don't know what emo hair is
Ashton Graves asked can we buy
memberships for other people
you can the only way to do it right now
is to put in their name and email
address but you pay for it that's uh
that's really the only the only way we
are gonna work on an improved system for
that at some point in time okay let me
say thanks to a few other people Emily
French is new member number 26 today
Thank You Emily how bright cloud is new
member number 27 Thank You Hal Brendon
Beckett is new member number 28 at join
pakman.com rich Leonard's is new member
number 29 today Brett Merkin is new
member number 30 at join pakman.com
black ops FX is new member number 31
thanks black ops Matt Knights is new
member number 32 today also want to say
thanks to Zachary pre Kowski who is new
member number 33 and Jorge Cervantes is
new member number 34 at join pakman.com
and I believe the website hasn't crashed
during any of this it's gone to yellow
it's gone from green to yellow but it
doesn't look like it's gone to red and
it's back to green now which is exciting
very very exciting ok
other super chats I mean al rifai says
do you like pac-man I presume you mean
the video game it's ok I you know since
growing up everybody would always say oh
did you dud invent the game so I always
kind of got annoyed and I never really
got into the game although I do think I
have a predisposition to be good at the
game let me mention that but I I never
got that good Alan says how difficult is
it covering these conferences every day
and listening to them lie daily I feel
like I've lost hope and common sense
well just look at my hair and beard to
get a sense of how difficult it is I
mean this this is my physical appearance
clearly something about these is not
good right I think we can all agree with
that Chris Bradley has sent a dollar a
a pound I'm sorry a pound m'kay crisp
says despite being a British lefty
I wish Boris Johnson all the best and a
fast recovery but will people back home
actually comply with the rules now 3000
people were out sunbathing in a London
Park on Saturday yeah you know people
say don't you wish that the people who
are not heating the social distancing
guidelines don't you wish that they get
sick no I don't what I do wish is that
only the people ignoring the rules were
at risk if you came to me and you said
listen here's the thing about the virus
if you ignore the rules you will get
sick but nobody else will I would
actually say you know what these people
are stupid but they're only putting
themselves at risk ultimately it is
their decision unfortunately they're
putting everybody at risk and aside from
not wanting anybody to get sick and die
the reality is it's not just oh it's not
just the people ignoring the rules that
are at risk everybody is and that's why
it's so toxic it's weaponized really let
me say thank you to massive oats for
grabbing at which Prime subscription as
well as mr. Gekko mr. Gekko has
subscribed with prime JH WH says you're
disheveled hair merely reflects our
collective emotional state after
numerous Trump briefings your suffering
helps us in these trying times very well
said and poetically so Beaufort says I
think we all have a case of the co fitco
vid quoi for right now yes Brett Hess
says losing my job at the end of the
week so have some of my paycheck oh jeez
again I don't want anybody's last
dollars okay all the folks that are
signing up and people who have
generously grabbed memberships at join
pakman.com I want to be really clear
we're all in this thing together if you
can afford to support our program of
course we welcome it with open arms I
don't want anybody's last two dollars or
five dollars we're all in this together
we're all trying to get to the other
side of this thing for lack of a better
term make it simple says oops sorry
when a bunch of super chats come in it
scrolls up make it simple says was David
sent to the electric chair I just got
here what happened we'll see 137 says
how do you think the world would react
if a head of state died from coronavirus
I hate to say it but it depends on the
world leader it depends on the world
leader love inspired says is there a
prize for bingo or just for fun it's
just something to make these a little
more tolerable we have sent the link out
in twitch chat and YouTube chat I invite
you to play trump briefing bingo you can
using the link in the chat you can
randomly you can randomize a bingo board
tremendous is the center square it's
sort of the free square that's the
center square on everybody's boards but
you can generate your own board bingo is
too easy so I'm actually going for a
full board and you know it's anyone's
guess whether I'll be able to do that
tom Bicknell says it's pronounced Vic
null but good effort okay big null
beacon all beacon all interesting Steve
salts zaid's says he shoots he scores
love it
junus call says have been lurking for
ages have a bit to give at the moment
stay safe much love from Estonia oh I
love Estonia I was there last uh when
was I there last I guess it's been about
a year last April loved Estonia a
beautiful place tall and is fantastic
the people are so nice the food is great
it was just a great place absolutely
loved it
let me say a few other thank-yous to
people who have signed up on my website
Paul Leno or Leno is new member number
35 today
damin Hammond what Damon Damon Damon
Hammond is new member number 36 okay I
sounded stupid when I said damin
obviously that's Damon Dominic Rossi is
new member number 37 today Ashton graves
is new member number 30
Helen dresser is new member number 39
and our Lee Jacinto is new member number
4-0 at join pakman.com very much
appreciated okay okay yeah Dammann was
stupid I get it guys I get it that was
not my best work not my best work thanks
to Ashley Pierson for the super chat
thanks - good job buddy
for grabbing a youtube membership
Kowalski from Nebraska says how long
until you've got a man bun it would it
this is nowhere close to being able to
turn into a man bun
I know it looks long but it's really
it's really not that long it would be
probably I don't know I think it would
probably be another two months
before I could even even come close to
getting some kind of a man bun together
Timothy says why are you not getting
rebuttals from our real leaders in the
Democratic community live on television
after these disastrous live filled
briefings well I don't know when those
are scheduled for and we're doing our
broadcast show and these and there's
only so many hours in the day is
essentially the answer Patrick
talismanic says what do you think what
do you say to people who still think
this is a partisan attack I really at
this point don't talk to those people I
mean if you still think that the virus
is fake or whatever III have no business
speaking to you and have no interest in
speaking to you if most presents says
love the hair love the show I heard you
say the f word for the first time just
now so here's ten bucks oh thank you
shaumbra lame has grabbed a soy boy
subscription Rhine Lyons says who do you
think will become the next Chancellor of
Germany in 2021 I don't know I don't
know enough about German politics to
know who are even likely likely
participants moose Stocki says at what
point do Berks and foul Chi lose
credibility for their proximity and
because they run interference for Trump
and pence so for me Burks has already
lost
90% of her credibility and you know foul
qi i thought she has calculated that
he's better off being there than not
even if he is limited in what he is
allowed to say now on that note this is
from yesterday let me pull this up
yesterday Donald Trump did not allow
doctor foul Chi to answer a question
about chloroquine and we now know that
there was a huge fight in the Situation
Room about chloroquine on Saturday so
check this out this is from yesterday of
foul Chi not allowed to answer the
question what's the weigh in on this
issue of hydroxychloroquine what would
you think about this and so there it is
Trump not allowing doctor foul Chi to
answer that question we later found out
that on Saturday in the Situation Room
during the coronavirus taskforce meeting
there was a blow-up about chloroquine
where doctor foul Chi and this bomb
throwing economist Peter Navarro were
arguing about it only one of the two as
you might suspect is a medical doctor
and clearly that is related to Donald
Trump yesterday simply not allowing
doctor foul Chi to answer the question
and very very sad very very very sad
welcome if you are watching on Twitter
twitch Facebook and YouTube we are now
about 23 minutes behind today's
scheduled White House press conference
expected to start at 5 p.m. Eastern we
are now nearly a half hour past that now
if you're joining me on YouTube please
do me the favor of hitting like and
subscribe like and subscribe is really
important as I also mentioned we did
take a big hit big hit in March on our
YouTube our website memberships 389
people cancelled webs website
memberships in March because of what's
going on so we are asking and I
I'm asking if were you a couple bucks a
month is not a stretch consider grabbing
a membership at joined pakman.com 40
people 40 people have done so so far
during the stream and it is really very
much appreciated and we've actually been
relying on on on the website memberships
because everything is just down you know
this uh this economy was not meant to be
closed but it must be that's the reality
and we're gonna we're gonna do what we
can to get through it let's see here
Jacob Ratner says do you agree with
considered from to be a fascist Trump is
not a fascist but he is authoritarian in
many of his instincts and we have seen
the United States slide towards
authoritarianism but it would be
incorrect to say that Trump is a fascist
good job buddy says I just subscribed
you are a very attractive and if I
wasn't married to such an amazing man I
would find you lol love the show all
right well there you go I exclusively
date women so I don't know from the name
good job buddy who we're dealing with
here but that is fascinating
Keith M says David's blow dryer goes BRR
Zachary Monroe says how do you think
history will remember Trump I have a via
clip up on my youtube channel about that
check it out I think that that's a
complex answer much affected by the
reality of right-wing media Twitter
social media and the echo chamber that
that has been created that will play a
big role in how Trump is ultimately
remembered let me say thank you to Laura
Bell on che who is new member number 41
today Terry Holden is new member number
42 Jordan haddock is new member number
43
Jeffery Hovey is new member number 44
Jim Chapman is new member number 45 and
Olivier carrion is new member number 46
why is my phone blowing up with
voicemails and all sort
of crazy things Wow it is you should see
what's happening on my phone right now
it's absolutely insane someone is gonna
pay the price for it that I can assure
you it looks like we're getting closer
to the start of today's White House
coronavirus press briefing scheduled for
nearly a half hour ago
other super chats coming in jacqui round
has subscribed at the SOI boy level on
YouTube Charlie says I'm playing a side
bingo card with short period of time and
you know it and I know it and we'll see
what happens yeah those are good
additions to the bingo card if you are
just joining us this is not to minimize
the seriousness of coronavirus it's just
out of a need to try not to be crying
the entire press briefing we do have a
bingo card we can share the link again
in twitch chat and YouTube chat I can
see the moderators sending that link you
can generate your own bingo card which
will randomize the locations of all
squares other than tremendous which is
like our free square and we will be
playing along when this ultimately does
start whenever that might be and we
don't know unfortunately when that's
going to be thanks to Zev Dean's for the
super chat and Lucy slay 'la as well as
Willy Wonka
Shapiro's dead cat oh whoops hold on a
second where did that go where did
Shapiro oh there it is Shapiro's dead
cat says better to have unkempt hair
than kovat 19 absolutely I will gladly
wait to get a haircut as long as I need
to if I can stay safe from the virus
very much agree neder Hernandez has
grabbed the subscription Tove a ayran
Becker has grabbed the subscription
tragic magic says David you almost pass
for Trump's hair double John a Hearn has
subscribed Alan Q says grande de eat
tend rien que el programa como en casi
Shawano la televisión expand estan mala
pero bueno
Boris Anu Joan Allen Daniel Allen the
UNA would ask so even fanfare wanna okay
so let me translate says there should be
programs like yours in Spanish Spanish
TV is not good but that is why I don't
listen to anything in Spanish someday a
hug from a Peruvian fan always love our
fans from Peru Thank You Ashton graves
says have you read primacy of politics
by sherry Berman
I have not graph 0 says not only is you
super saiyan hair Sian Sagan say on
Super Saiyan hair a sign of the times
I just went to bushes chicken here in
Austin and they gave me a roll of toilet
paper with my order that is interesting
Andre Sutherland says hope you and your
family are safe the UN gave props to the
government here in Costa Rica thanks to
how they have handled the virus
something to be celebrated very much so
stay on is I think my favorite
pronunciation of it graph 0 says your
hair they gave yes I got it thank you to
Ana Burgos for getting a YouTube
membership we don't do any YouTube drama
nonsense so unfortunately I'm not gonna
read anthony foul she's comment who is
obviously the user formerly known as
alex jones you know so we're not we're
not stupid here stephen jackson says
david usually my hair looks like yours
after watching a trump coronavirus press
conference Bryan Holaday says why does
Epoch Times run ads with you they're
running ads on news and politics in
general they're not deliberately running
ads on our Channel volker demon says I
can't believe what's going on in the US
this huge amount of Trump propaganda is
unreal and it seems to work greetings
from Germany greetings to you as well
Jamin Lee says what happens to your show
after if and hopefully Trump fails to
get elected are you going for Pro
Democrat or neutral well no I mean
listen if Joe Biden
becomes president we celebrate that
someone not as bad as Trump won and then
we pushed Joe Biden to pass progressive
policy and if Joe Biden is too centrist
which he likely will be we criticize him
from a progressive perspective that's
that's what we do no change in terms of
advocating for progressive policy let me
say a few other thank-yous
Geoffrey goro is new member number seven
forty-seven today at join pakman.com
Olivia R is new member number 48 at join
pakman.com Chris hunter is new member
number 49 at join pakman.com and Mary
Gates is new member number 50 can you
imagine
let's go for 75 number 51 is Luke Osteen
Luke Osteen is new member number 51
today and Janelle Jensen hey Janelle
Janelle is new member number 52 oh very
very important okay people asked I
believe it was yesterday about what is
happening with the David Pakman show
apparel because of kovat 19 our primary
apparel manufacturer had to fully shut
down production of data mail and other
t-shirts we have found a new producer
and they have seamlessly picked up all
production of data mail and other gear
so these are back in business and we
have a few other colors available now
banana cream was like the really popular
color this new vendor doesn't have
banana cream but they have this color
called sand I guess this is called sand
no that's not sand which one is this
natural okay so if you liked banana
cream you have to go with natural but
yeah
production has restarted of data mail
t-shirts and we've been sending them all
over the world
turquoise heather gray a very popular
color
we now have light gray some people felt
that heather gray was a little too dark
we now have light gray and we also have
sand so many many options if you want
the data male t-shirt
we are back in production very exciting
stuff thank you okay sazar atado says
can you say be valid rasa and ftp you
look right now you know I'm not gonna do
I don't want to do stuff that I think
could be turned into propaganda in some
way so I'm gonna try to keep that to a
minimum let's see here
bull shot in but has grabbed a youtube
subscription is my El Serrano says plans
on going on Rogen's podcast what do you
think of his view of Biden's candidacy
yeah so listen um I was hoping to make
an announcement this week about a Rogen
thing because of the virus there's a
large question mark around it
so I'm gonna have to delay the
announcement but hopefully news soon
about that and for sure I would talk to
Rogan about his I would vote for Trump /
Biden comment which I vehemently
disagree with and I look forward to
being able to speak to Joe Rogan about
that soon
keep it real cam says last conspiracy I
heard was this was the only way China
could get back at us without being
obvious
yeah I mean you've got a you're I've
seen brains on conspiracy and it's bad
very very bad actually speaking of which
I do have one other clip I want to show
you as we wait here let me see where
this is uh here it is okay I've never
been covered in the blood of Jesus maybe
you have maybe somebody can explain to
me what this means driving out of this
Ohio parking lot is a woman who just
attended a church service with dozens of
other people including children can I
ask you about your decision to go to
church to be inside that building
wouldn't be anywhere else aren't you
concerned you could in fact other people
if you get sick inside there's a certain
look that unhinged trumpets have in
their eyes and I've never been able to
sort of describe it correctly and this
woman has it there's a certain look when
they're asked the question where there's
a certain sort of like a disdain for the
media a disdain for the left a disdain
for non-believers maybe it is a cult
look yeah I'm not sure exactly but this
woman has that look anyway here's the
rest of the video covered in Jesus's
blood let me go woman who just attended
a church service with dozens of other
people including children can I ask you
about your decision to go to church to
be inside that building I wouldn't be
anywhere else aren't you concerned you
could in fact other people if you get
sick inside I'm covered in Jesus's blood
I'm covered in Jesus's blood other
people who don't go to this church who
you might improve all of these people go
to this church but you're gonna be in
places where the grocery store every day
I'm in Walmart thank you very much and
of course ignoring the idea of her
getting someone else sick so that is
that that is wet that's one of the most
severe cases of weaponized ignorant
arrogance and religious delusions that
I've maybe ever seen and you know this
this stuff is not fun and games kids
right people are dying here it's very
very bad and that's what we're dealing
with that's what we're dealing with and
it is tragic it is very very tragic if
you're joining me on YouTube welcome we
are at this point some 36 minutes past
when this press conference was scheduled
to begin if you are watching on YouTube
please do hit the like button and hit
the subscribe button it costs nothing
and it really helps our streams grow and
sixty three hundred folks currently
watching over on youtube about a
thousand on Twitch
which we love about 800 on Facebook and
I don't know how many are watching on
Twitter it's usually like a hundred it's
not it's not the best over on Twitter
but we're building we're just building
the audience it's okay all right other
super chats coming in Jason Fleury has
grabbed a soy boy membership Christian
burr DL says have you considered make
with other youtubers youtubers a hold a
channel we have not considered that we
have not considered that Michelle y
splat Dane says Trump and Giuliani own
stock in the chloroquine will have a
report about that tomorrow
Richard Minturn has grabbed a
subscription Helen Alderson says I
haven't worked since March 13 hoping to
be able to work again right here in San
Francisco when all is said and done I
hope you are able to get back to work as
well Helen Paul Newman what where'd that
go Paul Newman says I will shower you
with money as long as you spread the
word that Donald J Trump is a lunatic
Americans are good people and they
deserve competent leaders we certainly
do we certainly do
Bret Harte mrs. David would you go on
the rad stroller seems it's a twitch
dating show if you're not aware well I
was on Rajoy Al and I won actually so
please check that appearance out I I
defeated a gentleman who is known
publicly as airsoft fatty I defeated
airsoft fatty looks like we're getting
close now so get your bingo cards ready
link is in the twitch and YouTube chat
get your own bingo card ready as it
looks like we are getting close I am
going for a full board today I don't
care about bingo or double bingo I want
a full board today let me say thank you
to a few other website members very
exciting David Ervine is new member
number 53 today Rachel Fischer is new
member 54 at join pakman.com Thomas
McCrory no wait
McCrory mcgrory
is new member number 55 at join
pakman.com
and I think oh I think that's it yeah I
got everybody there very good okay thank
you so much let's continue with super
chats although it looks like we're
getting close here Harvard a oust bow
has signed up on YouTube guy Walker has
as well
Jamal Swift says hey DP your thoughts on
the DOJ seeking emergency powers to
detain people indefinitely without trial
during emergencies should we be scared
will it happen we should be scared I
don't know if it'll happen and I have a
whole clip on it on my youtube channel a
Jammu oma wale says look up dragonballs
I'm kidding
Dragonball Z I just I don't care about
Dragonball Z that's the reality let's
see we've got people coming out they are
placing the 30 days to stop the spread
card on the on the thing there here is
dr. Burks and Admiral gerar and dr.
Anthony foul she who is apparently not
going to stand on the stage nobody
wearing a mask and no is the
presidential seal normally on here when
Trump will speak I guess not I guess
they don't put it on in this room
otherwise that would be a signal Trump's
not coming out at all different scarf
sort of a more kind of actually this is
almost like a Girl Scout outfit right
like the brown dress with the blue scarf
dr. Burks adopting a bit of a different
look today and maybe we will see her
wrap the scarf around her face during
the during today's press briefing James
booty no says David do you smoke
recreational marijuana no I don't I and
it's smoking anything is bad for your
lungs you don't want to be smoking
anything s's theme 4s has grabbed a soy
boy subscription hey gar Ian says what's
your favorite color
blue wolf pack says get a haircut you
hippie sue Smithson and you've a G have
grabbed YouTube subscriptions Matt bond
says captain Crozier tests positive for
coronavirus 19 Boris Johnson in the ICU
two big stories big big stories let me
say thank you to Neptune 99 for the
twitch subscription ballin gee ma has
subscribed with prime Chad Rath has
subscribed with prime Ted lynn has
subscribed with prime as well thank you
so much for that support here is the
president as well as Mike Pence this
week America continues our aggressive
effort to defeat the virus as we enter a
crucial and difficult phase of the
battle we continue to send our prayers
to the people of New York and New Jersey
and to our whole country but right now
in New York and New Jersey are very hot
zones and well with them were with
everybody your struggle is our struggle
and we will beat this virus we will beat
it together I also want to send best
wishes to a very good friend of mine and
a friend to our nation Prime Minister
Boris Johnson we're very saddened to
hear that he was taken into intensive
care this afternoon a little while ago
and Americans are all praying for his
recovery he's been a really good friend
he's been really something very special
strong resolute doesn't quit doesn't
give up we have made tremendous progress
on therapeutics I had a fantastic call
today which I'll be talking about a
little bit later and I've asked two of
the leading companies is a brilliant
company's Ebola AIDS others they've come
with the solutions and just have done
incredible jobs and I've asked them to
contact London immediately they have
offices in London two major companies
but more than major more than sighs
their genius and
I had a talk with four of them today and
they speak a language that most people
don't even understand and I understand
something that they've really advanced
therapeutics and therapeutically and
they have arrived in London already the
London office has whatever they need and
we'll see if we can be of help we've
contacted all of Boris's doctors and
he's trump suggesting he's recommending
medications for Boris Johnson we're
ready to go but when you get brought
into intensive care that gets very very
serious with this particular disease so
the two companies are there and with
what they are talking about and it's
rather complex and and has had really
incredible results we're working with
the FDA and everybody else but we are
working with London with respect to
Boris Johnson across the country we're
attacking the enemy on all fronts
including medical scientific social
that's war logistical and economic we're
pressing into action the full power of
American government and American
enterprise and our military has been
incredible we've just sent 3,000 public
health personnel there now deployed in
the New York area and they'll be over at
the Javits Center over at the the great
ship and as you probably have heard and
I was informed that Governor Cuomo has
already told you and announced he called
me up a little while ago and yes whether
or not it would be possible to use the
ship with respect to fighting the virus
and we hadn't had that in mind at all
but we're going to let him do it and
we're also going to let New Jersey
Governor Murphy we spoke with him a
little while ago and New Jersey is going
to use it also because New Jersey is a
hot a hot spot
so governor Murphy and Governor Cuomo
are going to be using ship
New York New Jersey and it's a big ship
and it's now kovat it's set for covet
and we are going to hopefully that will
be very helpful to both the states the
Javits Center which is 2,900 beds just
built for our military also is going to
be manned now by the military and they
should be in place tomorrow and they'll
start sending quite a few people over to
the Javits Center it's convenient it's
right in the middle of everything so
that'll be something great and we
appreciate it
governor cuomo's nice really nice
statements and likewise governor Murphy
we have worked very well with both of
them and with frankly all of the
governor's vice president pence had a
call this morning with them that lasted
for close to two hours and I understand
there wasn't a negative person on the
call 50 governors or just about 50
governor's I think they were all on from
what I understood and they were very
positive about everything their federal
government has been doing for them and
you'll hear what that is and it's it's
rather amazing actually nationwide the
Army Corps of Engineers is building 22
field hospitals these are big hospitals
and altered at care sites in 18 states
so you have a combination of 22 field
hospitals in addition to that we're
building alternate care sites which is a
little bit of a smaller version of the
hospital and we have a lot of them and
they're going up in 18 different states
in total we've deployed 8450 hospital
beds from federal stockpiles and you
know if you think this has done over a
period of really a period of weeks it's
incredible actually more than 8,000
ventilators have been sent from the
national stockpile to our cities and
states backed by the defense production
Act which we've used very strongly very
powerfully there it is so powerfully
that we don't have to use it too much
frankly and it's nice to when you don't
have to
we're getting more than we ever
bargained for American industry is
stepping up manufacturers are really
going to town or we have thousands of
ventilators being built as we speak and
we have hundreds that are being sent to
different locations and we're ready to
roll with almost 10,000 that we have in
the federal stockpile when I say ready
to roll too I mean exactly what that
states we are wherever that monster goes
were able to move with it great
flexibility we have tremendous
flexibility and we have people waiting
and they're ready willing and able but
waiting to bring them wherever it may be
if they need it if they're needed it's
possible that they won't be needed that
we're fully stocked because numbers are
coming in where because of what the
American people are doing we're having
fewer hospital visits I think that could
be the case in New York it could be the
case in a few other states and fewer
beds fewer hospital visits mean fewer
ventilators so we'll see whether or not
our original projections were right but
anyway I had a very good talk with both
governor's and I think they're very
happy extremely happy about the what
we're doing for them yeah and especially
going all kovat so that'll take place
almost immediately coma alcove and HHS
have directly distributed eleven point
seven million and ninety five
respirators think of that there's Milly
get the number eleven point seven
million n95 respirators eleven point
seven million twenty six point five
million surgical masks 5.3 million face
shields four point four million
surgical gowns and twenty-two point six
million gloves twenty-two point six
million lives we have also arranged for
vast quantities of additional materials
to be allocated through donations and
existing supply chains we've also given
tremendous
medical material there's a place
throughout the 50 states and territories
and through project air bridge we have
succeeded in bringing plane loads of
vital supplies into the United States
from overseas we had an additional three
these are massive planes by the way the
big planes very big powerful and that
they're loaded to the gills with little
eyes and rather than bringing them into
our stockpile as we've discussed we
bring them to all the different
locations where they're needed so we can
save a big step and a timely step
because of my actions under the DPA I
can also announce today that we have
reached an agreement very amicable
agreement with 3m for the delivery of an
additional fifty five point five million
high-quality face masks face masks each
month so that we're going to be getting
it over the next couple of months one
hundred and sixty six point five million
masks for our frontline health care
workers so the 3m saga ends very happily
we're very proud to be dealing now with
3m and it's a CEO Mike Roman I just
spoke with him and I thanked him for
getting it done sponsored and Mike was
very happy to get it done great company
so we're getting one hundred and sixty
six point five million masks and mostly
that's going to be for our frontline
health care workers right okay that's 3m
thank you 3m I also want to thank Apple
one of the many great American companies
that's taken in 2 Timothy lept into
action today Apple announced that it is
now producing plastic face shields for
healthcare workers at the rate of 1
million per week 1 million and these are
the shields that you see on television
quite a bit and they're at the highest
level of quality and safety we're
grateful as well to Salesforce which has
donated 48 million
pieces of personal protective equipment
including masks gowns suits and face
shields Salesforce's is actually a
pretty good company I don't know why
they have so much PPE though I urge all
of our nation's governors to ensure that
the massive deliveries that we've made
to your state's over the past few weeks
are distributed as quickly as possible
so again we're working very well with
the governors now they may see you and
say oh we're not happy but they're very
happy on the phone and Mike Pence is a
straight shooter and he had a great
phone conversation to them with all of
the governor conference and they're very
happy every one of them right were there
any negatives no sir see I told you Mike
is the greatest Mike and you have done a
great job Mike and I appreciate the
whole country appreciates it
yeah right if they appreciate this right
don't you see everybody appreciates my
heart a special man so a lot of the
things that we've done again are going
directly to the states the state seem to
be very happy if they're not they can
call me directly they can call Mike
directly and we'll make them happy but
tremendous progress has been made in a
very short period and I think very
importantly the progress has been made
before the surge comes because the next
week week and a half is going to be a
big surge the professionals tell us and
I think we're in good shape for Dan
theny so it's good timing really good
timing we can have this stuff they are
already there for the most part but
we're bringing a lot of different
resources to to the various locations
especially where the surge is looking
like it's going to take place resources
from the national stockpile need to
reach our warriors and they are warriors
I tell it all the time I saw it again
this morning
he's young in many cases many cases
older but they're walking into the
hospital and they're putting on yeah I
mean as their doors open they're going
into this place and you know it's not
exactly too safe and they're going in
there and they're putting the outfits on
and they're putting their
on this routine account it's incredible
it's dope it's surely it's like no
different then you watch the war movies
you watch the old clips of war running
up hills it's to me it's the same thing
right men and women young and old but a
lot of young people just going in there
they're not thinking about oh gee this
is dangerous they're not saying well I
don't want to go in there warriors
they're running through those doors it's
the most incredible thing it's um
shocked because he was never depressed
an incredible beautiful thing resources
from the national stockpile need to
reach these warriors in the hospitals
immediately oh no I think it's starting
guys
and again the states have that
responsibility but we're working with
the states and we're getting the states
a lot of things that they can distribute
or when they tell us we bring it
directly to the hospital from the
federal stockpile or from the planes at
land which without even going to the
stockpile if any states having
difficulty distributing supplies we urge
you to use the National Guard to assist
in the delivery and I have to say you
have done a fantastic Deb would you know
that you've done great Tony you know
that you've done great but what a job
you've done and I appreciate it I really
did the whole has been incredible yes
mr. president that's a lot of stars you
have authority of that he's supposed to
do a great job when you have four stars
right but the military has been
incredible
right and I thank them for all of us
conversely if a state believes that it
has surplus equipment or supplies very
important because we actually have
gotten so much to some of the states
that they're able to now they've done a
fantastic job and they've kept they've
kept that line low and we have some
states that have surplus equipment and
supplies and they're working with us to
rapidly redeploy those supplies to areas
of greatest need we thought that might
happen if it worked out well that's what
was going to happen and it's happening
and I want to thank governor Gavin
Newsom who is doing a tremendous job
who's announced California will send 500
ventilators to be distributed to other
locations I think some are going to
Arizona some are going to Washington do
you see we think they're going to tell
what we're working through that but 500
excess ventilators from the state of
California and we're going to get them
taken care of wherever they have to go
those decisions are being made right now
right the members of the White House
Task Force and I are in close touch with
mayors and governors and hospital
administrators across our country and
we're told that the present time at the
present time most of the critical needs
are are being more than met not every
well states have to continue sharing
detailed information in the amount and
utilization rates of medical supplies so
we know what to resupply them or they
can get it directly that includes
ventilators they can get it directly
ideally if they can get it directly but
if they can't if they're unable to do it
we have tremendous amounts of supplies
that we're building it up very fast -
and this is before the big search this
information is fundamental to our
ability to deliver the material when
when and where it's most needed now Mike
in his conversation today I think got
some information as to a couple of
locations where we're going to be
delivering large numbers of ventilators
and large numbers of medical supplies
that will take care of that but some of
the states are very happy even governor
Pritzker from Illinois is happy because
he may not be happy when he talks to the
press but he's happy he's a very happy
man we're increasingly hopeful that the
aggressive mitigation strategy we put
into place will ultimately allow our
hospital system to successfully manage
the major influx of cases that that we
have right now
and I say that we're finding because of
the incredible job done by the American
people in conjunction with everybody
governor's the military federal
government state government local
government had a lot of conversations
with New York City and mayor de Blasio
gotten to know him I didn't know him
didn't know that got to know him
and a lot of people are working hard
everybody's working are a lot of people
are doing a great job tell you that a
lot of people are doing a great job but
the goal is that all Americans have been
sacrificing to achieve these last few
weeks things that a lot of people
thought
we're not possible to achieve and I
think we've more than achieved but we
have to go through again we're gonna
have a rough week we're gonna have maybe
a rough a little more than a week and
but there's tremendous light at the end
of that tunnel I said it last time said
it last night there's tremendous light
at the end of the tunnel there's so many
things happening with therapeutics with
vaccines with things that we really want
Deborah Tony they're all working so hard
on this but those therapeutics I mean
look the vaccines are going to be always
a little bit later because of that
testing period but the therapeutics
getting the kind of things that I heard
about today talking to these brilliant
companies and brilliant people on the
phone was fantastic was such an
incredible con Vanna Kathy and I also
spoke just a few minutes ago with vice
president former Vice President Biden
really called and we had a really
wonderful warm conversation it was a
very nice conversation we talked about
pretty much this this is what we talked
about this is what everyone's talking
about this is what they want to talk
about and he gave me his point of view
and I fully understood that and we just
had a very friendly conversation Wow
lasted probably 15 minutes and it was
really good it was really good really
nice I think it's very much so I
appreciate his calling okay as we
continue our efforts to develop
treatments and cures this afternoon I
spoke with leaders of
the American pharmaceutical companies
and just to give you their names
Amgen Genentech Gilead Regeneron these
are for the greatest in the world for
doing exactly what they're doing and
currently ten different therapeutic
agents are in active trials and some are
looking incredibly successful but we
have to go through a process and it's
going to be a fairly quick process I
will tell you based on what the FDA told
me and another 15 our plans for clinical
trials so they're advancing rapidly and
today a second company announced that
the FDA has authorized its vaccine
candidate to begin clinical trials cm
Johnson & Johnson is already there I
believe they're the one that's first and
now we have a second company that just
just announced and we were just was just
approved yes mr. president we have two
companies at that level for the vaccine
it's uh we've now performed 100 well if
you think of this 1.79 million tests
that's 1 million seven hundred and
ninety thousand tests nationwide and I
think we're gonna put up a screen here
someplace that there aren't you but just
don't kill and here it is this is the
process starting on 5 March and ending
right there
right about now right that's about it so
and it's going up at a rapid rate nobody
has done more testing and one of the
reasons why are they say and I think I
can say this Debra very strongly but one
of the reasons that we have more cases
is we've done more kenta more testing if
I went to some of these countries that
have in my opinion far more people than
we do that had the problem and if we did
the kind of testing proportionally the
window they'd have many more cases than
us but we have more cases because we do
much more testing so when you do the
testing you have cases otherwise you
wouldn't know about they got check we're
39th and testing per capita globally we
have now done
1 million seven hundred ninety thousand
tests nationwide that's more than any
other country in the world hence we have
more cases and that number is growing by
nearly one hundred and twenty five
thousand people per day think of that
one so it's gone by a hundred and twenty
five thousand people per day I told you
about South Korea this is a you know
vastly faster and we also have they say
the most accurate of tests right that's
CBS is launching and they've been great
too new drive-through testing sites in
Atlanta Georgia and Providence Rhode
Island and each location would be able
to test up to 1,000 patients per day
using the ultra-fast five minute test
developed by Abbott Labs now they're
down to five minute they go the
ultra-fast it's very accurate Abbott
Labs are one of the things that's not
even true it's not down to five minutes
it's that it's five minutes versus
fifteen for a yes versus no where no
versus yes something like that he
doesn't know what he's talking about
there's as of today tens of thousands of
small businesses have applied for more
than forty billion dollars in relief
under the Paycheck protection program
you've open it and it's really I mean
it's only been going for a couple of
days it's really been performing well
apply a couple of little glitches minor
glitches that have already been taken
care like no one has gotten money these
funds were resulted nearly two million
jobs being preserved so we're taking
care of our workers right small
businesses and our workers nearly three
thousand lenders have already made loans
under the program and we're signing up
additional lenders very quickly rapidly
not true community banks have been very
responsive and larger banks that we're
also stepping up if this pron out of
funds by the way we're already preparing
because it's going so fast for the small
businesses and their employees will ask
Congress to refill it immediately but
the banks have been great the big banks
the Bank of America was right up there
at the beginning JPMorgan Chase was was
husband yeah I spoke to Bank of America
they said you need to have both of the
deposit and lend
relationship with them as of February
15th Trump hasn't mentioned that as we
announced last week we are providing 100
billion dollars in direct support for
our hospitals and the first tranche 30
billion dollars will be distributed this
week so I want to want to say one other
thing our farmers we love our farmers
and as you know as of April 1st the
China trade deal 250 billion dollar
there is China they purchased two
hundred and fifty billion dollars from
us if not more and of that approximately
50 billion is expected to be with our
farmers so it kicked in as of April
first and we'll see how it goes it seems
like they're buying so we'll let you
know how that's going but they're buying
anywhere from forty to fifty billion
dollars worth of our agricultural
product that should have a huge impact
on our farmers a tremendous impact on
our farmers but we're watching it very
closely to fight the medical war we've
mobilized the unbeatable and it just it
is unbeatable strength of American
determination ingenuity and compassion I
got to see that when I spoke to the
great science because I call them
science companies more than drug
companies scientists yeah you would
we've seen businesses charities and
private citizens making generous
donations so many people are making
donations we've seen states and cities
supporting and helping each other and
caring for our citizens and we've seen
Americans of all backgrounds and beliefs
uniting together to answer the challenge
and rise to the moment and that's what
they're doing above all we've been awed
and inspired by the exceptional courage
of the doctors nurses EMTs and health
care workers who are the soldiers of
this war no words can ever express the
complete measure of our gratitude for
these intrepid heroes really has a way
with one Cleveland patient credited his
medical team for not only saving his
life through their skill but for ever
changing his life through their example
of selfless devotion couldn't believe
it's so generous he
was with his statements and he talked
about their bravery in an area that was
in such trouble an area of that hospital
where people were dying and he talked
about their bravery another survivor in
Houston said simply I will consider them
my angels forever I will consider them
think of that my angels forever as our
nation endures the depths of loss and
grief
we are also witness to the summit of
American virtue character and courage
with the love and dedication of every
American patriot we will win this battle
we will defeat this enemy and we will
rise from this present crisis with new
strength unity and resolve and that's
what's happening tremendous stories are
coming out of this horrible moment very
dark moment for the world
182 I was saying 151 for a while and
then it got up to 160 and it's 182 as I
announced yesterday hundred and
eighty-two countries
his friend didn't even know about a
country by this virus so I just want to
thank everybody I want to thank the
American citizens for doing a great job
stay inside and let's win this and let's
get our country open as soon as we can I
think it's gonna be sooner than people
think things are going really well again
light at the end of the tunnel most with
that I'll take questions and then Mike
is gonna take over and talk with the
Admiral and with the professionals and
we appreciate you being here yes please
mention things we're asking this drug
companies provide treatment to the
British prime minister what sort of
treatment is that well it's a very yeah
it's a very complex treatment of things
that they've just recently developed and
that they have a lot of experience with
having to do with something else but
recent for this this guy and they'll be
they've already concurred they've
already had meetings with the doctors
and we'll see whether or not they want
to go that route but when you're an
intensive care it's a big deal so
from saying they're ready I think we
have way of three over we spoke with
four you know who the four would be and
for what
you know the people within those you
probably you'd know the companies I told
you the companies but the people at the
greatest oh my god in the world so
they're at the hospital and which and
they have they have everything with them
should it be needed hopefully hopefully
we won't have emanated we should have
been needed I just I found him I found
Boris to be a fantastic person just like
a fantastic warm strong smart guy he
loves his country right you see that I
mean he fought like like hell for his
country and intensive care is big stuff
really big stuff yesterday you were
asked about this as well but now that
you can move to intensive care does that
give you and the vice president any
pause or additional concerns steps that
you're taking to preserve the continuity
of government here no I don't think so
Mike had his test a couple of days ago I
had my test couple of days ago so and
we're here and here you are he doesn't
really think you know I don't think so
but I think we'll probably just because
of questions like that I think we'll
probably have maybe quite a few tests
it's not the worst idea you know the
system of testing that was so quick and
so easy
obviously the ideas they should not be
together so they don't both get it
[Music]
States has done the Inspector General
for the Department of Health and Human
Services released a report today a
survey of more than 300 hospitals across
the country and the number one complaint
from those hospitals were severe
shortages of testing supplies and
lotions long wait time I mean did I have
the word Inspector General really it's
wrong and they'll talk to you about it
it's wrong no it's well where did he
come from the inspector general what's
his name
it came from the inspector what's just
merit I don't know his name well if I'm
using it let me know okay can you find
me his name I'd appreciate it but Sir
these are all I can tell you use this
and put up on the board
you're gonna ask given st Admiral but we
are doing to get there we've done more
testing and had more results than any
country anywhere in the world they're
doing an incredible job
Wow now they're all calling us they want
our testing I'm waiting what are you
ready how do you do the five-minute test
how do you do the 15-minute test the
same time to be the name of the
inspector general could politics be
entered into that go ahead sir go ahead
thank you sir are you worried about
retaliation to your decision to Bent
export of medical goods like Indian
Prime Minister Modi's decision to not
export hydrogen hydroxychloroquine to
the United States other countries I
don't like that decision if that's I
don't I didn't hear that that was his
decision I know that he stopped it for
other countries I spoke to him yesterday
we had a very good talk and we'll see
whether or not that says I would be
surprised if he would you know because
India's does very well with the United
States for many years they've been taken
advantage of the United States on trade
right so I would be surprised of that
worse decision he'd have to tell me that
I spoke to him Sunday morning called him
and I said we would appreciate your
allowing our supply to come out if he
doesn't allow it to come out that would
be okay but of course there may be
retaliation why wouldn't there be
yep
mr. president the Paycheck protection
program had gotten off to a confusing
start for small resolution wells fargo
has stopped taking applications
Bank of America not any more than you
probably weren't I taking applications
from clients that were already Thank You
Ben the leaders taken tremendous numbers
of application is no clue of course
there may have been they wanted to have
a snow deed if there has been what they
wanted have a little different
information but Bank of America has been
a leader they number one in terms of
applications
I wish you'd ask the question
differently why don't you say it's
gotten off to a tremendous didn't bar
the question but there are some little
glitches which by the way have been
worked at there would be so much nicer
if you do that but you're just incapable
of asking a question in a positive it's
taking the measures it's taken the
measures and we may even do a different
system now this we're gonna have to
probably add more money to this to save
we know to keep our small businesses
going and to keep the employees of those
small businesses working but it's such a
positive event and you ask it in such a
negative way it's just I wish I wish we
had a fair media in this country and we
really don't
I told the crew
well that captain Crozier when either
quote too naive or too stupid to be in
command is it appropriate for the chief
officer an apt speaking his way about
this captain
well I haven't heard it exactly I
haven't heard I heard they had a
statement that was made if that were the
statement how he likes having this
reality the letters shouldn't have been
sent and certainly they shouldn't have
been leaked this is a military operation
I must tell you I've heard very good
things about the gentleman both
gentlemen by the way I will say this but
about both gentlemen and I may look into
it only from the standpoint that
something Shan resolved because I'm
hearing good things about both people
there does I may just get involved if
it's okay with you yeah because you know
you have two good people and they're
arguing and I'm good believe it or not
at settling arguments I'm good at
settling these arguments so I may look
into it in great detail in detail and
I'll be able to figure it out very fast
but that was a statement it's a rough
statement but look look letters should
not have been sent to many people
unclassified that was a mistake
it's a mistake that shouldn't have been
made because it's unfair to the families
of the people on the ship because they
get nervous and it shows weakness and
there's nothing weak about us now not
anymore we have the strongest military
we've ever had and we're not going to be
showing weakness to anybody because we
have that ship is incredible
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier and we
don't want to be doing writing letters
we don't want to have letter-writing
campaigns where the fake news finds a
letter gets a leak we don't want that
it's fake so the letter excuse me so the
letter shouldn't have been sent with all
of that said his career prior to that
was very good
so I'm gonna get involved and see
exactly what's going on there because I
don't want to destroy somebody for
having a bad day okay does that make
sense
okay mr. president Vice President
Biden's spokesperson said that he made
some suggestions to you about actions
that you could be taken he deal with the
pandemic we had a very good talk we
agreed that we weren't going to talk
about what we said but we had a very
very good talk there was a warm talk I
enjoyed it I hope he enjoyed it too and
he was short it was 15 minutes
suggestions it doesn't mean that I agree
with those suggestions but certainly had
suggestions and had them I also told him
some of the things we're doing but the
conversation was a very friendly
conversation
yeah thanks a lot mr. president you've
mentioned other members of your task
force have mentioned over the course of
the next two weeks it's going to be a
very difficult time for our country in
terms of fatalities and there it will be
a difficult we can have and there are a
number of Governors who are close allies
of yours mr. president who have
refrained thus far to have these stay at
home orders and dr. Falchi who of course
is one year your task force has said
that drew it would the states that don't
have stay-at-home orders are putting
themselves at risk and the country well
let's give dr. foul she said that I
would be inclined to call them up you
know we do have a competitive underlying
problem in doing that you understand
that there's a double there's a double
edge so do you understand I can do it
but it is a constitution recommending
has no constitutional issue two
different reasons where I would rather
have the governors do it make their own
determination they're smaller and not in
all cases but sort of the smaller cases
but I'm not sure 100% that doctor foul
she said that but you can ask yeah let's
get telling you up there I have good
conversations with the governor of
Nebraska and the governor of Iowa here
and it's it's interesting that
functionally even though they have not
given a strict say at home what they are
doing is really functionally equivalent
to that and we had a really good
conversation with with both of the
governors and that it you know when I
had mentioned that I think there was a
public response that they weren't really
doing anything at all and they really
are doing a very good job both of them
those are the only two that I spoke to
but but it was a really good
conversation and I want to make sure
people understand that just ask em
questions I don't have a very strict
stay at home water they haven't placed a
lot of things that are totally
compatible with what everyone else is
doing good about getting back to normal
you said you wanted to get back to
normal as soon as possible will we truly
get back to normal in this country
before there's an actual vaccine that's
available to everybody well what in how
d8 how do you start lifting the
restrictions yeah what will John if back
to normal means acting like there never
was a coronavirus problem I don't think
that's gonna happen until we do have a
situation I'll can completely protect
the population Wow but when we say
getting back to normal we mean something
very different from what we're going
through right now because right now we
are in a very intense mitigation when we
get back to normal we will go back
gradually to the point where we can
function as a society but you're
absolutely right I mean if you want to
get to pre corona virus you know that
might not ever happen in the sense of
the the fact that the threat is there
but I believe with the therapies that
will be coming online and with the fact
that I feel confident that over a period
of time we will get a good vaccine that
we will never have to get back to where
we are right back now so if that means
getting back to normal then we'll get
back to normal which I have total
confidence are coming I'd rather hear
from pouchy the whole time at Johnson &
Johnson I'm talking to all of them I
think that when you add the tremendous
stimulus that we're giving like for
instance deductibility for restaurant
expenses we haven't done the restaurants
and entertainment has nothing to do with
the money that we're talking about for
small businesses and employees to keep
everybody working in other areas that
we're frankly working on right now which
are going to be great for our people I
think when you add that to it I think we
could get more than back to normal from
an economic sample it actually be better
but more than back to normal but I I
would agree that we'd love to see a
vaccine but immediately we would love to
see a therapeutic right and I think we
very close you think you'll be able to
lift restrictions on April 30th right
now there's only comment on that but I
can tell you that we certainly want to
try we certainly want to see what what's
going on we're doing very well look you
look at those you look at most places
where that you can call it the bump you
can climb getting at least May 15
because whatever you want to do it it's
very flat you take a look and that was
done through a mitigation that was done
through a lot of good work and that far
exceeded our expectations before I mean
you would people can't even believe how
how low some of those bumps are some of
those hills are they're very surprised
they have a couple of tough ones New
Jersey's been very tough in New York has
been very tough they're crowded in you
know it's tight it's tougher but we far
exceeding California far exceeds
Washington State far exceeds you look at
so many of these states how well they're
doing the eight states by the way and I
haven't spoken to the governor's but
Tony's so right they may not have it
from the standpoint that they're saying
it but those people are practicing it
and they're doing a fantastic job take a
look at where they are notice four five
layers away from the question else but
take a look where they are so but if I
thought it was something that and I've
looked at him and I've looked at him
very carefully looked at him today
looked at him yesterday from a
constitutional standpoint I'd love not
to get involved with it and not from a
legal standpoint just from a moral
constitutional standpoint because
legally I can but morally you know I
believe in our Constitution much more so
than most people untrue and I'd love to
be able to let the governors do what
they have to do those states are doing a
fantastic job all eight of them they're
doing a fantastic job so we'll see what
happens as for your question you fully
understand what I'm saying so thank you
yes I too
I may involve somebody outside the room
of thirst to the cast gun do you think
Boris Johnson when he talked about so
shaking hands of hospital patients did
he downplay the threat of this virus too
much and do you know exactly what this
car I think Boris was looking at it
differently he was looking at it earlier
he was looking at it like write it out
there were many people thinking about
writing it out meaning you know whatever
it is it is but then you see what starts
to happen and the numbers become
monumental and they decide not to do
that we actually moved early we moved
early because of what we did with
respect to the ban on China coming in
and then Europe coming in that was an
early band 2 and then UK so no he he
waited a little while and he he felt
that but he got you know he made a
decision very quickly thereafter to do
what they did and they they've gone
through a very strict lockdown but this
suffering greatly question was about
shaking hands with people in hospitals
you know they're they're a nation that's
having a difficult time but I've gotten
to know him he's just such an incredible
guy he was just so shocking to say that
because you know what that means
intensive care is a big deal with regard
to what we're talking about that's a
very big deal very scary deal yeah
social distancing has asked me to ask a
question it's the thomas Howell of the
Washington Times how many health workers
in the US have become infected with
Kovac 19 live dance is not known will
the CDC be publishing recitation I think
that I think they'd probably be willing
to give that right yeah we could get you
that information Jeff mr. president OPEC
is meeting on Thursday and they have
said that there
to make a cut in production if the u.s.
chips in as well which suggests that
they want you to ask us producers to do
enough show me that I don't know we'll
have to make that decision and maybe we
will maybe we won't but we'll have to
make that decision it's you I think the
cuts are automatic if you're a believer
in markets
I can guarantee you there's a cut from
pre this condition you know look this
happened because of the virus the virus
knocked out 40% it was it went down in
one hour I mean literally when places
close up you're talking about a 40% cut
no I think it's happening automatically
but nobody's asked me that question yet
so we'll see what happens I'll let you
know Thursday evening
that's the deal but you but you would
consider asking us companies why they
just automatic because they're already
cutting I mean give you look they're
cutting back because it's its market
it's demand it's supply and demand
they're already cutting back and they're
cutting back very seriously but if OPEC
is asking for a single well nobody so if
they ask me I'll make a decision okay
but no but again it's happening anyway
yes please
it might have all the discussion about
Prime Minister Johnson and his health
and can you update us on the state
so the second half of your visibility
so I had a physical or the first half
was very successful I did it on a day
when I was in the White House and we
were able to do that as the deprived
courted and I have some the second half
of the physical different probably has
done it Walter Reed and I'll do that at
the appropriate time but I feel very
good and according to the doctor a very
good shape can you imagine just ask you
again on the idea of a national stay at
home recommendation what is giving you
so much pause about well I appreciate
your own just not the Constitution of
the United States and I'd rather have a
recommendation for the governor's to
make the decision if a decision was very
necessary to reckon they have done a
good job and I don't know said it better
than anybody they are they are doing
they are doing what we're asking them to
do without having to put the seal on it
but the recommends say if I thought it
was necessarily do it in a heartbeat
free with the Georgia governor's eye
opening the beaches opening I haven't
seen I'm gonna have to see to what
extent I'm gonna have to see how many
people you're talking about a lot are
they crowded are they packed
are they not packed we'll have to take a
look at it right now it's very early for
beaches in Georgia Soph right now very
early so I'll take a look at it he's
done a very good job as the governor he
knows what he's doing but I want to take
a look it really does depend on you know
how crowded it may be but I will talk to
him and I will ask him that question I
would ask of me a person
travel restrictions around hot spots
that's something that's still on the
table on that one we're looking at it
and the airlines have been cutting their
routes you saw that yesterday they
announced big cuts and routes we need
some some flights for emergency use for
military people we need some flights for
medical people and there are very few
flights as you know and the flights that
are going out or I think they said
they're three to four percent full Wow
you have three percent of the plane
that's occupied so it's they're very
very generally very very empty planes
but it's good to have it's a it's a tiny
amount of flights relative to the
overall and we need them also for
medical workers for otherwise we're
gonna have to do a whole big thing with
our own planes so this is tradition
every commercial flight actually can
create more problems those planes and
also when people get off the plays
follow up on this question of the HHS
Inspector General by the way her name is
Christie grim and it wasn't so much her
opinion but they interviewed 323
different hospitals I'm still good when
was she appointed when was she appointed
I'm not sure what she was would you do
me a favor let me know no I have to know
now John let me know because we are
doing an incredible job in testing we
are doing a better job than anybody in
the world right now in testing there's
nobody closed and other nations admit
this other nations have admitted it very
strongly other nations are calling us
wanting to know about our testing let me
know when she was appointed would you
specifically what he was saying was a
third of the way in the okay thank you
very much
chyna full of medical supplies companies
like far away and Alibaba has been
donating the United States my million
and ninety five months and also a lot of
medical gloves and much more medical
supplies it sounds like a statement more
than a question Chinese investor to
attend high last night Rhoda of add
value of times calling to cooperation
with the United States so are you
personally working directly with China
trade deal it's the biggest deal
probably ever made and I hope they're
gonna honor that trade deal right they
don't honor the trade deal then I'll
tell you a different answer but I think
they will they're gonna spend billions
of dollars for agriculture they're gonna
spend billions of dollars for many
different things
whereas trying to never spend money in
our country we spend money we had a
deficit a trade deficit with China four
years of 500 billion dollars four
hundred billion dollars we had the
biggest trade deficits in the history of
the world with China now China's gonna
spend a lot has agreed to spend 250
billion many billions of dollars in our
car not an ant luxury but going to
farmers and manufacturers so I'll let
you know I mean I I hope they're gonna
honor the deal well for them working for
China I work for China are you with a
newspaper who you with is it all by
China or is it owned by the state Hong
Kong do you okay good okay look I'll let
you know I'll give you a good answer to
that in a few months I want to see how
do doctors do bus okay it's time right
now for China to help explain it and
hopefully they do and if they don't
that's okay too but we signed a deal it
was signed in with great goodwill and
spirit and esprit de corps that our
farmers benefited our manufacturers been
fit it and we'll see whether or not that
deal is honored and I think it will be
because I know President Xi who I like
and respect she and I think he will
honor the deal he made with us it just
went into effect four days ago I will
see whether or not in fact I called up
just a little while ago I said how the
farmers doing with respect to China are
they buying the product as anticipated
and the answer was yeah I think so but
it wasn't the most positive but it was
it was starting it was the deal just
started so I'll let you know but you
know for many many years China ate our
lunch because we had people in this
position that I'm in right now
that allowed China to get away with
absolute murder and it should not be
Obama but we are we are now dealing with
China we'll see what happens
to your question you must be she was
appointed in January of this year the
principal deputy inspector you said that
businesses have applied for 40 billion
dollars in loans but can you tell us how
much of that money has actually gone out
to this moment I can't tell you but I
know it goes out very quickly once the
loan applications approved and if the
process is very fast and you have to
understand these are banks and that's
what they do but they were swamped they
were actually swamped okay go ahead I
know you don't want to talk about
general report but testing is still a
big issue in this country what
when can hospitals in Spanish whether
they're going to receive their cycles
could do their own testing also states
can do their own testing are you
supposed to be doing testing hospitals
are supposed to be doing testing do you
understand that with the federal
government listening with the federal
government we're not supposed to stand
on street corners doing testing they go
to doctors they go to hospitals they go
to the state the state is a more
localized government you have 50 of them
and they can go 50 within you you also
have territories as you know and they do
the testing and if you look at the chart
if you take a look they put it up yeah
just take a look I don't think we can
say Trump's visibly sweating yet but at
that upper lip is starting to gloss a
little bit so we'll keep an eye on that
because that is a bingo square it and
not really prepared we have a brand new
testing system that we developed very
quickly and that's your result and you
should say congratulations great job
instead of being so horrid in the way
you ask a question so I can talk a
little bit more about testing later on
but as the president said 1.79 million
tests if you close your eyes this guy
sounds a lot like Glenn Greenwald
hundreds of thousands of tests that are
done within hospitals that are now
currently not reporting so I'm sure well
over 2 million that Inspector General
report was done for quite a long time
ago there was clearly and it's hard to
interpret the report because it mixes up
all kinds of things but clearly there
was complaints by some hospitals of a
backlog probably I'd say guys what the
hell is dr. Burks doing true there was
several days of backlog at some of the
major labs that have been taken care of
we know now that the AC la labs now have
a 24 to 48 hour turnaround they're doing
well over a hundred
and test today we now have the Abid
machine that's point-of-care that's 18
thousand of those instruments throughout
the country the Cepheid machine is now
all across the country with a 45-minute
turnaround so we have worked directly
with many of the hospitals that have
their own laboratory derived tests some
of those really quite frankly didn't
understand the regulatory freedom they
have to use other different kinds of
instruments or different kinds of
reagents so a little bit delayed on my
Morse code but did dr. Burks just blink
torture in Morse code everything is
clear we have the 24-hour call number
but that's what it was it was there for
and I don't know the Inspector General I
don't know that person I tell you one
thing I have a problem with if there was
such a problem that she knew about or he
knew about on March 23rd and 24th why
did I find out about the tests from them
on the on the news media at 8 o'clock
this morning if there was a problem I
think your ethical II obliged to tell me
where that is so we can interact with it
like I do every single day but that's a
discussion for the future I think
testing is really in a good position
right now and I'm be happy to expand on
some of the really good tests that are
coming up with the previous menu bomb
administration thank you for telling me
that see there's a typical fake news
deal
I told you what she was before here a
third when your race reporter and what
you just said is a disgrace okay you
asked me you said sirs got ashamed of
you take a look at what you said now I
said when did they when did this person
how long is governor well it was
appointed in the Obama administration
thank you very much John thank you very
much you will never make
but how can you tell us today how many
ventilators are in the federal stockpile
I'm not going to tell you how many are
in the stockpile but I can tell you that
we look at ventilator use granularly I
say today in every single state and down
to the hospital level trailer we have
been able to meet and easily meet all
the ventilator requirements that have
been brought us to us by the state
no one has not gotten a ventilator that
needs a ventilator and as far as we can
project looking at all models every
person who needs a ventilator will get a
ventilator I'm a ventilator doc right
I'm an ICU physician for it was that the
service end every day to serve on
ventilators this is my community it's
also the surgeon general's community as
an anesthesiologist so what we have in
the stockpile I think is not a number
that we we give out but we have
thousands remaining in the stockpile and
now you're seeing either out of the
appropriate American spirit that when a
statewide election 10 or California
doesn't need that ventilator they're
doing the right thing by moving them
around the country about 9,000 just so
you understand 9,000 and by the way you
didn't tell me also that this Inspector
General came out of the Obama
administration
okay please go ahead you didn't go ahead
I was just quickly here I'm looking at
the this Inspector General's bio a
person of certain government since 1999
does hoping to ask you about is there
something that you learned on that phone
call and half as soon as viewers before
the call you need about speaking to
people I just think he's very nice I
think he's a nice man I've always
thought he was a nice man I've I don't
know him I don't know if I ever spoke to
him before other than to say oh you
imagine has been in government 21 years
and it somehow Obama's fault both see
now the counsel of some of your
predecessors but no not really
we're doing a great job hey I inherited
we this administration we inherited a
broken system both militarily
well we've rebuilt our military well we
now have so much ammunition whereas you
remember it very important general sense
sir we have no ammunition there's the
third planning for sure I want
ammunition they didn't want to save
money because they spent money like
nobody ever spent money but you know
what we now have a great military built
that we have so much ammunition we don't
know what to do with that he's really on
hand it's a nice feeling to have trigger
they also gave us empty cupboards the
cupboard was bare you've heard the
expression the cupboard was bare this
her so we took over a stockpile where
the cupboard was bare and where the
testing system was broken and old and we
redid it and frankly it would be okay
for a small event but not for a big
event and they had a chance to do it
somebody said that a certain person I
won't tell you but a certain person said
this will happen and that's true the
problem is that person never did
anything about technical illustrations
in previous it was he talking if it did
anything about it you know we all know
all about pandemics and all of the
things that we're seeing now but nobody
thought it was going to happen and if we
did think it was going to happen
the problem is nobody did anything about
it we made that we built the system and
now we're a fine-tuned machine we built
thousands of hotel beds found out all
right we moved a ship in that now we're
going to make four kovin kovat 19 we are
going to make it so that people having
this horrible thing happened to them
will be able to use the ship to ship
as I said is going to be shared with New
Jersey New York and New Jersey we've
done things that are incredible when you
built what was it 18 hospitals we've
built 18 hospitals we built Medical
Center's all over the country and when
you have gavin newsom and other
governors who really have been very nice
and generous in their statements because
they make the statements to the press
not just in my face others tell us how
great we're doing like the call that
Mike had today I heard from other people
that were on the COI said it was
incredible was two hours and was
everything was positive they were so
happy with what we've done and we're
ready to do more if they need it because
we're ready to March
the Admiral can tell you we are sitting
there with 9,000 ventilators and we're
ready to March when we see that we can
move very quickly as soon as we see that
need we can move very quickly we're
ready here March we built a great system
the problem is the Democrats like a guy
like Chuck Schumer's a total lightweight
by the way I've known for a long time
he'll say why don't you put a military
man in charge the military man I have
all military men this man is doing an
incredible job we have two Admirals
numerous generals we have the Army Corps
of Engineers we have FEMA we have this
whole force that like nobody has ever
seen before we have a great military
operation and they've done an incredible
job they got a pull him off and honestly
people should respect because nobody's
ever seen anything like what we've done
and what they end up with forget about
me know what I felt on here yep like
you've never snide will only get out
it's bad if I say how many ventilators
do you need a thousand would be great I
said no probably gonna send you 10,000
and then you'll call up from the media
you'll say how did Trump do we're not
happy he didn't send us enough families
because let's call politics but if you
look at what's happening that and I'm
even surprised the governors are saying
all good things but the Democrat
governors and a couple of rhinos frankly
they're rhinos so they are one Murano in
particular but the governors are saying
great things he had a call that lasted
two hours today perfect be heard about
they call
not just for Mike it was a perfect call
now they were on the call even though
you're not supposed to be I'm sure the
calling some of the media was on the
call because they're constantly
reporting the goal if they're honest
they will say it was a great call okay
okay next question the hospitals that
were built in New Orleans in Dallas
today but you've mentioned them a number
of times previously there seems to be
some concern in Texas that they might
lose the hospital in Dallas if it's not
we're only we're only helping Texas by
the way the governor is doing a great
job over there with this situation and
Texas is so big you have some parts of
the state that are affected other parts
that aren't affected at all you know
it's an incredible place keep this
hospital unit that's unused or is the
family gonna shift those resources
possible well we're gonna use whatever
we need and we're doing it totally in
conjunction with the government here's
no clue okay no doing it in conjunction
literally no access governor's done a
fantastic job it also has set up
checkpoints at the border to check
people coming from Louisiana you've seen
checkpoints and other state borders
Americans very few people are coming
through our border and you'll be happy
to know RuPt a mile 161 of the wall he's
talking about the us-mexico border
questions about state borders on the
border between Mexico we have 161 miles
he's not asking you're not used to
seeing border checkpoints between states
how much first you want us to call eight
governors and tell them to do something
and then you're complaining that another
governor is so strict that he actually
checks the borders I understand why he's
doing that because he knows who he has
and he doesn't want people coming in if
they should maybe you know not be -
these are the like info of the doctors
no I think it's look most done a great
job he's done a great job in this case
as have many other definitely has done a
great job one of the things I thought
you're going to say is we
been very tough on our southern border
he wasn't talk very very tough now and
part of that's because of the fact that
we have so much you know when you talk
about a hundred and sixty miles of new
wall nobody's coming through that weird
last week he said 120 now it's 160 40
miles in like three days leave we will
have early next year we'll have close to
500 miles of wall which is what our goal
was he promised a full wall by the end
of his first term friends call today and
he said that he believes that a kovat
for relief bill will be necessary do you
share that belief on what would be
contained
I don't know necessarily but I certainly
want to listen and what I want to do is
two things
a real infrastructure not a green new
deal you know the carbon footprint I'm
not looking for the carbon footprint we
want to put people to work but a real
and frankly for so many years we've let
our infrastructure go to hell because we
were wasting all our money in the Middle
East and other places okay I want to
rebuild our country I don't want to
rebuild that we're tired we built we've
rebuilt if you call it that or destroyed
frankly what we've done is so crazy what
we have done the direction that this
country has taken is so sad but we're in
the Middle East for eight trillion
dollars and if you want to fix a pothole
in a highway you can't do it because
they don't want to give you the funds so
we want to have an infrastructure bill a
real one like in the vicinity of two
trillion dollars to completely rebuild
our roads our bridges our highways our
tunnels everything and I'm totally open
to listening to that I'm also open to
listening to and even putting forward
because we're going to be putting
something forward more money for our
citizens because they've gone through a
trauma this has been trauma this came
out of nowhere where and I say it and
I'll say it again we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world
we had the most people working in the
history of our country almost a hundred
and sixty million people far more than
ever before
and then one day our professional so
listen he's just thought so I'll tell
you that is the work of the labor force
participation troll so the population of
the u.s. keeps growing so atmo
times we have more people working than
ever before and more people not working
than ever before when it was Obama they
would say there's more people than ever
not working
now that it's Trump they say there's
more people than ever working well
there's actually both the population
continues to grow she said on Saturday I
asked dr. Bruce Lee clarify something
that she said on Saturday if I'm a
doctor Brooks this is a question that
comes from a radio colleague of mine
Tamara Keith on Saturday it sounded like
you said that for the next week people
in high-risk areas should not even go to
the market or the drugstore is that what
you meant to say well where is that
accurate you know out of respect for
every single health care worker that's
on the front line whether they're a
nurse a doctor
a respiratory therapist the phlebotomist
the persons who come in the rooms to
clean you know out of respect for them
we as Americans should be doing
everything possible and what I meant was
if you can consolidate if you can send
one person the entire family doesn't
need to go out yes on these occasions we
really need this is a highly
transmittable virus we've been saying
that we want every American to know that
what they're doing is making a
difference but we need to have
solidarity of commitment from everyone
to really so you know maybe once every
two weeks we can do a grocery store and
pharmacy shop for the entire family so
it was really about we have to do
everything we can I know I see on the TV
stations the level of human suffering in
the hospitals doctor Falchi and I and
Admiral Jarrar have spent our lives
taking care of others we need to take
care of each other now as Americans and
do everything that's in those
Island and I know they're tough I know
incredibly how tough they are my
grandchild of 10 months got a fever of
105 this weekend I'm the doctor and I
couldn't get there I mean so I was
trying to explain to my daughter how to
listen to her lungs
how listen to her lungs and I do not go
there when you can't you can't take that
kind of risk with the leaders of the
country daughter but she's yes but you
know we're all and that's just an
illustration that I know you all are
making sacrifices and I guess I want
everyone to take this seriously so that
was really a call of seriousness of how
important this is and how we're starting
to see the impact but you can see what
can happen when you come at this a
little bit too late it's a lot of times
that's why the message before you see it
before you have to see your hospitals
and your emergency rooms overwhelmed it
is on us as a member of community comes
doing the Swivl guys yes do everything
possible to save one another and so that
was really what I was saying and I will
continue to say that because I do
believe it's making a difference you can
start to see it you also look for we
have to do even more right now because
that will predict where we are two or
three weeks from now big difference I
saw where Governor Cuomo was a little
bit upset today over the weekend a lot
of people outside and where they were
pretty good big groups of people I saw
that I noticed that it he wasn't happy
with that and I could understand that
look we have a period a short period of
time
hopefully it's a short period of time to
go and let's get it done let's get it
done
Kristen did you have a course thank you
so close oh just got here ecology
yeah quick followed to the question
about legislation I know there's
discussion about a face for what are you
also looking seriously at a second round
of direct payments and are you putting
the discussions on a potential phase
four and four now while you receive that
well I was opposed to the way of
distribution money distribution through
as you know unemployment and through the
state offices because they have very old
come not all of them but many of them
have 40-year old equipment as I've said
and it makes it very difficult but
that's what they're looking that's what
they want to do that's the way it's
mandated to do I thought it would be
better if we did a direct payment system
but the Democrats really wanted it and I
think they had some some help from a
couple of people that I would have had I
spoken to him I would have convinced him
otherwise I really believe but so but
it's getting out and the federal
government has done its job all we can
do is give this massive amount of money
to the states the states then are
responsible to distribute it a little
bit like we're talking about here but
the money will be right on time from the
federal government then the states have
to do their job in getting it in we
could very well do a second round of
direct I would do it direct under
serious decision so it is absolutely
under serious consideration Wow
in terms of truck Schumer he also said
he spoke to
chief of staff about potentially
appointing a Sartre yes see this could
be Ronald claims that's something that
you are so talented I know the people he
suggested they're wonderful people they
worked here they're wonderful people
he's just doing that because it's
politics because you know we have many
depending on what in terms of testing
this gentleman right here in term you
know who the point person is this
gentleman right here he's the one who
chose it but Mike you may want to tell
him about oh no oh he was talking I
thought he was talking about vouching
supply chain it's a very good question
and I spoke to Senator Schumer night
before last about just that when the
president signs run a declaration of
national emergency he stood up FEMA is
the lead agency implementing his policy
to marshal a whole-of-government
response and under FEMA we provide
federal support the state manages the
healthcare response and health care
providers and first responders implement
that response on a local level our lead
on this issue and implementing it is
administrator Pete Gaynor but the man
managing all of the supplies and you
heard a presentation this weekend about
our air bridge what we also call the
control tower we we literally with with
Admiral John pelagic at the helm of our
logistics effort we have visibility now
on all the supplies that are moving
across this country and into this
country from around the world it really
is extraordinary I mean when the
president tapped FEMA to lead this
effort tapped he we essentially wanted
to say we want to organize this in a
military fashion and we tapped really
someone who is widely regarded as the
number one supplies and logistics
military officer
to do just that he really is an
extraordinary individual ad murder is
knowing for a long time and to be
working with Admiral pelagic we speak
every morning our team reviews that data
this is meat all over that with with
administrator Gaynor and Admiral pelagic
we talked about an extensive team that's
identifying supplies around the country
and around the world and then as we were
explaining to governor's today we work
with the requests that are coming in
from States with a priority on the areas
that are dealing with widespread
outbreak like the the Greater New York
City area in New Jersey
Louisiana focus on Detroit focus on
Chicago and Illinois and then what what
feat gainer and Admiral pelagic are
doing is directing those commercial
distributors to send the resources
directly to the front lines of the
battle against the coronavirus it is an
extraordinary system and as I explained
to the governor's today as I've
explained to congressional leaders
who've made a what I think is a is a
good faith recommendation that we have
that we organize this in a manner of
military logistics it's exactly what
President Trump has done and right what
we're doing every single day to make
sure that health care workers to make
sure that the states that are dealing
with a widespread out back chronic virus
can be confident that we're gonna spare
no expense leave no stone unturned and
use this extraordinary apparatus
centered in FEMA to get the people of
our country what they need when they
need it to battle the coronavirus
and Kristen when humor makes a statement
like that he's only done it for politics
he knows we have the best generals the
best Admirals we have the best people
these are incredible leaders these of
vibrant people they've done such a good
job and again you'll get a tape of the
conversation because I'm sure some of
the governor's probably had their
favorite reporter listening to the
conversation even though they weren't
supposed to but that's happened before
just so you understand we had a call
today that was a beautiful call
everybody friendly coronavirus Boise
they also know in some cases we'll get
them a little bit more and if they need
it we'll get them a lot more depending
on where this monster is going but when
Schubert is does that take a look take a
look at the past well you're gonna have
to tell me great at that they certainly
dog well yeah some Democrats because
they view this as a campaign issue they
want to make Trump look as bad as they
can because they want to try and win an
election that they shouldn't be allowed
to win based on the fact that we have
done a great job out loud
we built the greatest economy in the
world I'll do it a second time we got
artificially stopped by a virus that
nobody ever thought possible and we've
handled it and we built a team and we
built an apparatus that's been
unbelievable take a look at the swine
flu right that's h1n1 take a look at
that and it's not the other way around
by the way it's h1n1 take a look you
know what I mean by that take a look at
the swine flu it was a disaster 17,000
people died the other administration
didn't know it was like they didn't even
know it was here and that was peanuts
compared to what we have in terms of the
power the magnitude of what we're going
through oh boy this is attacking 182
countries simultaneous is not a good
direction this is pretty much just all
about politics I've known him almost all
of my adult life and he's a disgrace in
many ways he's a disgrace and he knows
it's done he just wants to do that but
he knows the job we're doing everybody's
amazed at the job with
and that public is starting to find out
this you know one of the reasons I do
these news conferences because if I
didn't they would fact-check Trump's
approval on coronavirus is down down
down T's with that those ACS with this
talent they see the job that Mike Pence
has done which has been an unbelievable
job an unbelievable job I put him there
I thought he'd do well he did great as
the governor of Indiana and I thought
Mike would do well he's done much better
than well and he gets along with people
I think much better than I do imagine
that because I like people being 100
Mike can put up with things that
sometimes I say it's amazing that he can
put up with it but he's done an
incredible job and so has the entire
team this is a military operation and
again we built two thousand nine hundred
beds in Javits Center
so he's unhinged I mean these things
have nothing to do with the question
from Kristen Welker nothing nothing
nothing to do a thousand beds much more
now in McCormick Place that's their big
convention home the equivalent of Javits
shattered you know big lobbies fantastic
place by the way the mayor of Chicago at
least on the phone is extremely happy
with what we're doing thanking us this
would be the type of thing like in
Freudian psychotherapy would be like
free association where the therapist
says very little and Trump goes from one
topic to another to another and next
thing you know you're seven layers away
this was a very specific question about
Chuck Schumer
[Music]
the national security front to the
extent that you can comment on this your
administration is making heavy
preparations to move in Latin America
right now and I kid you said what
America yes did you expand on the
reasoning why now are there supply
logistics especially weak political
what's the reason good question
we've moved a tremendous number of boats
and ships to the area of you know
different areas of exactly where you're
talking about
I'm cuz we are tired of whatever it is
that amount from other places and we're
tired of seeing drugs pouring into
different parts of Latin America South
America and just coming into our country
now we've got them stopped at the border
and they're trying to do it by sea so we
stop them at the border with and frankly
with the help of Mexico Mexico right now
is twenty-seven thousand soldiers on our
southern border they never had any
soldiers right at doing that because
I've asked them to do it that's the only
reason they're doing it they have 27,000
soldiers so now they're trying to bring
it in by boat and by ship the drug lords
and the people doing drugs and trying to
destroy our doing drugs consider the war
on drugs maybe as an element here very
very hard and that's why is it beyond
there are the activities of human
trafficking and especially with respect
to women and as you know proportionally
it's mostly women and it's a horrible
thing it's a horrible thing and there's
never been a time like it and it's
because of the internet and this is all
over the world but for the most part
they're coming through in this country
they're coming through the southern
border but we're hitting them very hard
they have tremendous illegal trafficking
and women and children also but mostly
in women and it's illegal and it's
horrible and it's disgraceful and I've
seen things that are an absolute
disgrace
yeah and we're trying to knock them out
and when knocking him hard and again I
want to thank the President of Mexico
because he has really stepped up to the
plate
only 7,000 soldiers they'd never had any
soldiers on our border and I did that
because the monic rats will not approve
anything to stuff because they want to
have open borders they want to have all
these people flowing through our border
and in many cases they're sick they have
problems that you don't want to know
about were they're criminals in many
cases not in all cases but in many cases
and they don't want to have what they
won't have open borders they won't have
sanctuary cities so they protect
criminals
lie lie lie lie lie lie and Joe Biden
doesn't want to have that also as you
die because I said that during numerous
debates I want to have strong borders
and I don't like protecting criminals
with sanctuary cities but we're doing it
for drugs we're doing it for human
trafficking we're doing it because you
have to do it we have borders so we
don't have a country from question of
antibody testing which is FDA approved
now but not widely available yet I know
if the Admiral set by May you expect to
have millions available how are we gonna
prioritize who's gonna get the antibody
tests and what does what is that going
to show you no I think that's gonna be
immunity so let me clarify and I know
you probably understand this as the
antibody test does not tell you if you
have the active virus in your nose if
you're a positive for the antibody it
strongly implies it means that you have
had the virus before and to the degree
that we know of medical knowledge you
will probably highly probably be
protected against getting the virus
again in the future so I want to make
something clear on there's no antibody
test approved
okay approved is not a word we talk
about there is a test or two that has
received emergency use authorization and
many many many others out there that
have not gone that way yet and I want to
take this opportunity to caution there
is a very consolidated effort between
the FDA CDC NIH to validate some of the
tests that are on the market right now
yes because it is very important that
they actually do what they say they do
right
and we have reason to believe that not
all of them are gonna perform well yeah
I don't know the primary source but the
Financial Times just reported that the
UK had seventeen point five million
antibody tests that they bought and none
of them work so we're not going to get
in that situation we're going to be very
careful to make sure that when we tell
you you're likely immune from the
disease you're really that test really
said that now I will also make a
statement and I'm there's a lot of work
on here and I'm very excited about it as
opposed to the test for a novel virus
the antibody type tests are very
sophisticated technology but they're all
technology this we expect to have many
tens of millions of tests the first
month that we are really sure that the
test makes sense that's good news so
this this allows for surveillance
screening and dosages is one of the
world experts to understand is one
percent five percent twenty percent of
Americans have been infected but it also
allows us to have very widespread tens
and tens of millions of people screened
with a finger prick on the spot just to
do this my man you're saying so
so we're science doesn't run on rails
right so we need to make sure that the
FDA the NIH which they're actively doing
right now
assure that the test that they're
testing really do with perform the way
they should and if things work out the
way we believe they will we will have
millions on the market by May in a
sophisticated way in a prospective way
that we get the surveillance we need we
can test people to see if they've been
exposed immune and go back to work and a
combination of that kind of test with
the current kind of test we have now is
how America opens back up now let's hope
sometimes we gets those Testament ends a
billion we're a country of 300 million
how you determine who you're gonna have
how that test well we were having active
discussions under the leadership of dr.
Burks in the task force but you can
imagine how that is right but with tens
and tens and tens of millions of tests
per month that are available you could
really do wide very widespread testing
but let me just give you an example
nobody else
no other country can do I'll just give
you one example it would be very
important to know if the virus is still
circulating here whether for example a
healthcare worker or a long-term care
nursing home worker is immune from the
virus and can't carry it right very very
important to protect our elderly in that
situation but also if you haven't been
exposed to make sure that you really
take precautions and maybe take care of
the people who don't have the virus and
you don't have the virus so they're very
it's complex but it's not complicated on
how you go about looking this in
different segments of society and I
don't want to take too much more time at
the podium but antibody tests are a
different thing
they're coming we're highly confident
that this can be scaled very rapidly and
provide us a bit of information we just
don't have them indeed and then Mike is
taking over and you're gonna see some
incredible work that's been done please
follow up on what you said with regards
to captain Crozier before you say you
didn't want to punish him for having a
bad day that day would be a bad week
what does that but I don't yeah I want
to I'm going to look into it and I I
also I also think our Navy Secretary's
highly respected man so sometimes that
happens with people and I'll take a look
at it what do you mean by that would you
consider reasoning he sends a letter out
and he sends copies all over the place
and it's not a classified letter and it
was very disconcerting to the families
of the people on the ship were very
disconcerting so number one they get
worried and scared it was weak we don't
want weak but I'm gonna take a look
because he's I think he you know looks
to me like he's an outstanding guy I
looked I looked at his home just a
little while ago I looked at his file
and people have bad days and we'll take
a look at it question is what would you
consider
well we'll take a look I want to look I
want to speak also to the secretary I
also want to speak to Secretary of
Defense who's Mark espers doing a
fantastic job and we'll you know maybe I
can help the situation out I mean you
guys just say why is the president
getting involved and going well I like
to sell problems it's a problem you know
I don't want to see men hurt women hurt
I don't want to see people hurt
unnecessarily maybe we can solve it
easily where you know it's not life
changing but he did he did a bad thing
sending a letter around and many many
copies as you know I don't know I heard
28 copies I heard a lot that's a lot of
copies plus the letter was five pages
long I haven't read the letter but I
think was five we know I'm single-spaced
sings a lot of writing
you know he's three inch margin ship
he's de he's a very important 18 points
of a very expensive ship a
nuclear-powered ship he should be
writing letters like that but it happens
sometimes I'll write a letter that I say
I wish I didn't send it
yes not too often but it happens because
I knew you were asked about this British
woman try it one more time he did say in
remarks to soldiers on the USS Roosevelt
that closure was quote too naive or too
stupid to be in command if he didn't
think that way well I understand it's
tough language but I don't want not get
into that
it's tough language there are some
people that they go wow he says it like
it is
look she made a mistake he should not
have sent that letter or he should have
gone through his chain of command which
is the typical way of doing it you know
he's in the military's a very important
person in the military he knows it
better than anybody in this room what he
should have done and I'm sure he feels
he made a mistake but I'm gonna look
into it and I'm gonna see maybe we can
do something because I'm not looking to
destroy a person's life who's had an
otherwise stellar career as I understand
it I looked at this file just now
because I've been seeing what's going on
if we can say
if we can save a person's career I don't
mind going after a person if they did
something wrong and you know but this
was a mistake he made a mistake I'm not
justifying what he did he made a mistake
shouldn't be sending letters he's the
captain he's a very important person in
the military you don't say the letters
and then it leaks into a loose a paper
of all newspapers that was a beauty
right see you just don't do that so it
was a mistake but I may get involved
I'll call Secretary of Defense and find
out a little bit about it and if I can
help two people to good people
I'm gonna help them I said when you
asked me and when the question was asked
the last time I said shouldn't have sent
the letter I haven't changed he
shouldn't understand a letter and it
should if there's a letter it should go
classified it should go to his superior
and he shouldn't be jumping over so it
hasn't changed in that regard the only
thing that has played right up here with
me is that I looked at his record Oh God
and he's been an outstanding person if
he wasn't I wouldn't even be talking
about this he's been an outstanding
person he's had a very exemplary
military career I mean you know he
started off as a helicopter pilot they
called him chopper his name was chopper
was a great helicopter pilot it's a
tremendous skill I know a lot about
helicopters
oh yeah and then he went to f-16s or
f-18s
and he was a tremendous pilot and then
he's very smart
he studied nuclear energy and he was
fantastic and very few people have the
aptitude they have the mentality to do
that nuclear energy is very complex very
it's very hard very few people can do
you got a problem and he did it well and
then it became the captain of a nuclear
ship right he became of a if a
replacement course if you look at
replacement cost 18 billion dollars a
replacement cause wait so he's got on a
replacement cost basis an 18 billion
dollar ship you know the President
Gerald Ford very expensive that
you know the nearest thing I can think
of but they're spending money on that
was like nobody's ever seen so he made a
mistake
he made a mistake and maybe we're going
to make that mistake not destroy his
life many doctors and workers today
sometimes seen cake cuts they're going
into it's nicer department where they're
concerned about their own health their
families and a livelihood if something
were to happen to very much you remove
and as part of this space for or ain't
go with you a face or I think it could
be a separate phase when it's all over
right now I don't think they want to
think about these people don't want to
think about these people are incredible
they're not thinking about how much am I
getting paid these people are incredible
I've seen it I see this burn I hear
about it all the time
from Mike from the Admiral I hear about
it all the time these people are
incredible when it's all over I do want
to seriously think maybe in the form of
bonuses these people are what they've
done is incredible
I just I just admire the attitude and
I've said it I just did they walk into
those hospitals and they are seriously
you know one of the things that came up
with the comfort the ship is that when
we fulfilled the request of Governor
Cuomo and Governor Murphy and they're
going to be splitting up but you know a
lot of things happen to ships when you
do that you know it's a lot of they
didn't want to do this in fact they
specifically didn't want to do this have
patients that were affected with this
horrible disease or whatever the plague
because frankly it's a plague that's
exactly what it is you'd read about it
in the old days the plague and the same
as the line is but we're doing it but
when I see the bravery of these people
walking through the doors without their
cell with a half they're just getting
with it they're not standing outside hey
let's get ready let's they're running
through doors putting on the stuff it's
not even horn I think it's incredible
I'm telling you the nearest thing I can
think of is soldiers in battle and
shoulders going right into battle
and is this what they're doing it's
really in many ways it's the same thing
all right how about one more question
mr. president you may have seen this the
Masters Tournament that's been
rescheduled to November two questions a
is that an outgrowth of your
conversation that you had with Sports
admission respond I hope I hope
footballs able to start I hope baseball
can get to play a little bit I'll pass
the ball maybe do their playoffs I mean
hey I have no I have no interests or
anything other than I want what's good
for the country a lot of people are
tired any times yeah a lot of people are
tired of looking at games that are five
years old look the other day I saw
somebody I said well he looks great
forgot I said oh that was nine years ago
yet I said he's really a great shape
well not in great shape now but he was
in great shape then Brighton's nine
years ago you know you get tired of
looking at nine year old baseball games
and now playoff games that took place
twelve years ago oh I don't have much
time to do that frankly but that's what
people are doing and they want to see
sports sports are a great thing for this
country and I hope football can start
and I told them I think you might be
able to they may very well be able to I
hope they can start and I hope they can
start with people in the stands you know
we're not going to be separated but you
have seats those seats are meant for
people to sit next to each other and
when this virus is gone people are going
to be sitting next to each other and
just for the restaurant industry so they
understand when the virus is gone people
are going to be sitting next to each
other right one man said I have a 200
seat restaurant it's been great but if I
go boy these rules this 200 seats goes
down to 60
I said don't know you have a 200 seat
restaurant that's what you have but we
have to wait till the virus goes away it
wouldn't even do well at 60 frankly
there's a warmth to it also if there's a
warmth you don't have the part of a
civil war well ladies thank you very
much so I'm gonna let our Vice President
take over he's got some really
interesting numbers statistics and I
want to thank the Admiral I want to
thank Tony and Deborah and everybody
else I want I think everybody that's
working and I really do I see a lot of
trim
things happen at the therapeutics the
call I had today was one of the most
exciting calls I've had in a long time
and again I want to wish my best to the
UK and the family of Boris Johnson and
we just hope he's going to be okay
because he's a fine guy thank you very
much everybody
all right guys and that's it for me I
will not be covering Mike Pence's sick
of fancy but I will join you guys again
tomorrow thanks to everybody who joined
me have fun with pence if you will be
continuing I will not